Hi, everybody. I'm speaking to you today from the stage of an opera house at the Brooklyn Academy of Music in New York City.
大家好。我今天是在纽约布鲁克林音乐学院的歌剧院舞台上向大家讲话。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
A warning to listeners that there is mild cursing throughout this hour, and on the podcast, we're not going to beep that. And I'm here on an opera house stage with a story that is so small, it almost feels wrong to tell it in a room this grand. It's actually about a real opera singer-- not a super-famous opera singer or anything like that. Carin Gilfry makes about half of her living singing. The other half she makes recording audio books.
给听众提个醒，这一小时的节目中会有轻微的脏话，在播客里我们不会消音。我站在歌剧院的舞台上，要讲的故事实在太小了，在这么宏伟的房间里讲感觉不太合适。故事的主角其实是一位真正的歌剧演员——当然不是什么超级巨星。卡琳·吉尔弗里（Carin Gilfry）一半的收入来自唱歌，另一半来自录制有声书。
And about a year ago, she was staying at a hotel. And she had a deadline on this children's book that she was supposed to be recording, and the hotel room was kind of noisy. She was hearing a lot of noise from the street. And so she looked around for a quiet place, and she went into the closet-- put pillows all around to deaden the sound, sat on the floor with a microphone. And then the cord of the microphone went under the door of the closet out to her laptop, because her laptop had a fan that made noise.
大约一年前，她住在一家酒店。她当时接了个儿童读物的录音任务，期限快到了，但酒店房间有点吵。她听到街上有很多噪音。于是她四处寻找安静的地方，最后钻进了衣柜里——在周围塞满枕头来隔音，坐在地板上架起麦克风。麦克风的线从衣柜门下穿过，连到外面的笔记本电脑上，因为笔记本电脑的风扇有噪音。
And so she closes the door so it's pitch dark except for the light from her iPad, which had the text of the book that she was supposed to read. And she began.
于是她关上门，里面一片漆黑，只有iPad发出的光，上面有她要读的书稿。她开始了。
The Exciting Exploits of an Effervescent Elf , written by Trisha Sugarek and narrated by Carin Gilfry. Chapter one, "Where is Emma?" The enchanted forest was deep and green and splashed with--
《活力小精灵的精彩历险》，特里莎·苏加瑞克著，卡琳·吉尔弗里演播。第一章，“艾玛在哪里？”魔法森林深邃而翠绿，点缀着——
Can I just say, wouldn't it be incredible if I just now played you the entire audiobook? You paid, like, $85 for those seats, right? Actually, I can't play you the whole audiobook because Carin gets exactly, like, two and a half sentences into this book. And she stumbles on a word, and she decides, oh wait, I'll just start again. I'll just start from the beginning.
我能说一句吗？如果我现在就把整本有声书放给你们听，那不是很棒吗？你们花了大概85美元买票坐在这里，对吧？其实我没法放完整版，因为卡琳读到这本书的两句半时就卡住了。她读错了一个词，然后想，哦等等，我还是重来吧。我从头开始。
So she gets up to get out of the closet and start the tape again, start the recording again. And she tries to get out of the closet.
于是她起身打算走出衣柜，重新开始录音。她试图推开衣柜门。
[DOOR RATTLING]
[门发出碰撞声]
Oh, [BLEEP].
哦，[消音]。
And she discovers that she's locked in.
她发现自己被锁在里面了。
[CHUCKLING]. Oh, my god. Seriously?
[轻笑]。天哪。认真的吗？
And Carin told me at first she thought, like, this isn't going to be that hard, right? After all, she has the iPad. There's Wi-Fi. She could call the front desk on Skype, right? But there was a problem.
卡琳后来告诉我，起初她想，这应该不难吧？毕竟她有iPad。有Wi-Fi。她可以用Skype给前台打电话，对吧？但有个问题。
This Wi-Fi was, like, half of one bar, and it kept just cutting out. But I found the hotel number.
Wi-Fi信号只有半格，而且断断续续的。但我找到了酒店电话。
This of course is on the recording.
这段当然也被录了下来。
212-661-9600.
212-661-9600。
[IPAD ALERT NOISE]
[iPad提醒音]
I dialed it.
我拨通了。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Thank you for calling the Roosevelt Hotel. Please listen carefully to the following options. For additional information about the hotel, please visit our website--
感谢您致电罗斯福酒店。请仔细听以下选项。如需了解酒店详情，请访问我们的网站——
And then, of course, it's, like, the longest hotel phone menu ever.
然后，不出所料，这是史上最长的酒店电话菜单。
--for sales and catering services, press 3. For accounting, press 4. For the human resources office, press 5.
——销售及餐饮服务，请按3。财务部，请按4。人力资源部，请按5。
I'm trying to press 0 to get to the operator. And I'm thinking the Wi-Fi is going to cut out at any moment. So I'm listening to this giant long menu, and finally I hear--
我一直在按0想转接人工服务。我心想Wi-Fi随时会断掉。所以我听着这个冗长的菜单，终于听到了——
If at any time, you wish to speak to an operator, press 8.
如需随时转接人工服务，请按8。
[PHONE BUTTON]
[按键音]
So I press 8.
于是我按了8。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Reservations. May speaking. May I assist you?
预订部。我是梅。有什么可以帮您吗？
Hi, I'm actually in room 1136.
嗨，我其实在1136号房。
Hello?
喂？
Can you hear me? Can you hear me?
你能听到我吗？你能听到我吗？
[CLICK]
[挂断音]
[BLEEP]
[消音]
After that, there's seven minutes of silence on the recording-- just, like, total silence. Nothing happens except every now and then, Carin just laughs to herself. It happens one minute and 48 seconds after the phone call. Then it's quiet. There's no other sound for 44 seconds. And then on the recording, you hear--
那之后，录音里有七分钟的寂静——就是那种完全的寂静。什么都没发生，除了偶尔传来卡琳自嘲的笑声。这发生在电话挂断后1分48秒。然后又是寂静。接下来的44秒没有任何声音。然后录音里传来——
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Now and then, she tries the door handle again, thinking, she told me later, this can't really be true. Like, this can't-- there's got to be a way this is going to work. One wall of the closet has the hallway on the other side. And 18 minutes after Carin locks herself in, she hears people. She hears some German tourists walking towards her down the hall. And fortunately, she actually has the skills for this very situation.
偶尔她会再去试一下门把手，心想，她后来告诉我说，这不可能是真的。比如，这不能……总得有办法解决吧。衣柜的一面墙后面就是走廊。在卡琳把自己锁进去18分钟后，她听到了人声。她听到有德国游客向她的房间走来。幸运的是，她确实有处理这种局面的技能。
[SPEAKING GERMAN] Can someone help me?
[德语] 有人能帮帮我吗？
The Germans come to the door of the room. They whisper to each other for a little bit. And then, they do nothing.
德国人走到房门口。他们小声嘀咕了一会儿。然后，他们什么都没做就走了。
Hello?
喂？
Her husband is out on an audition-- he's also a singer-- and his phone was turned off. She texts her mom, hears nothing back. She phones her mom. And right then, somebody taps on the door of the hotel room and calls through it. "Are you OK?"
她丈夫当时在试镜——他也是个歌手——他的手机关机了。她发短信给妈妈，没有回音。她打电话给妈妈。就在这时，有人敲了敲酒店房门，在门外喊道：“你还好吗？”
Yes! Please, come in!
是的！求求你，快进来！
"Can you come to the door?" the person asks.
“你能走到门边来吗？”那个人问。
I can't. I'm-- I'm stuck in the closet. [CHUCKLING]
我不能。我……我被困在衣柜里了。[轻笑]
Hello? Where are you?
喂？你在哪儿？
In the closet right here. Oh, thank you. [LAUGHTER] I'm an audiobook narrator--
就在这衣柜里。哦，谢谢。[笑声] 我是个有声书播音员——
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
--and I was  trying to narrate a book.
——我刚才想录一本书。
Good. Oh--
好的。哦——
Oh, my god.
天哪。
Carin knows that's a really weird thing to say to somebody as you're getting rescued, but she just couldn't help herself. Nobody wants to look like a nut, you know? Apparently the Germans went and they found this very sweet Jamaican housekeeper. And 22 minutes after Carin was locked in, the housekeeper set her free.
卡琳知道在获救时说这种话很奇怪，但她实在忍不住。谁都不想看起来像个疯子，对吧？显然那些德国人去叫来了一位非常贴心的牙买加裔客房服务员。在卡琳被锁住22分钟后，服务员终于把她放了出来。
God, I was so happy to see her. And she was so nice. Oh, my gosh, she was so nice.
天哪，见到她我太高兴了。她人真好。天哪，她真的太好了。
I know this is a weird question, but is it appropriate to tip in a situation like that?
我知道这问题很奇怪，但在那种情况下给小费合适吗？
I don't know. I didn't think of it then.
我不知道。当时我没想过这个问题。
Now Carin, remember, she's an opera singer. And operas are all about spectacle. It's 80 people on the stage and horses and love and vengeance and big, grand feelings. It would really be hard to get further from that to what happened to her in that closet, right, where all the action takes place in a space not much bigger than your body. It is the simplest plot imaginable. There's literally no movement in this plot.
记住，卡琳是一位歌剧演员。歌剧讲究的就是宏大场面。台上80个人，还有马匹、爱、复仇和宏大的情感。要把场景切换到她在那衣柜里的遭遇实在太难了，对吧？那里的动作空间还不到你身体的大小。这是你能想象的最简单的剧情。在这个剧情里简直没有任何动作。
If someone were to stage this as an opera, how would that go?
如果有人把这个排成歌剧，会是什么样？
It might be minimalist music, actually.
可能会是极简主义音乐，其实。
Oh, right.
哦，对。
Like, just a repeating theme over and over and over again with me yelling, help!
比如，一遍又一遍重复同一个主题，伴随着我的尖叫，救命！
And you know, people say those kinds of things in interviews, and then I'll put that quote at the end of the story. And it makes for a nice  ending-- put a little plinky music under it. Maybe you've heard our show.
你知道，人们在采访中会说这类话，然后我会在故事结尾加上那句引用。这会是个不错的结局——配上一点叮叮当当的音乐。也许你听过我们的节目。
But when we did this interview three or four weeks ago, I realized, oh, wait a second. For once in my life, I don't have to let this story stop here. I am actually going to be in an opera house very soon. I can reach higher with this.
但我们在三四周前做这次采访时，我意识到，哦，等等。我人生中第一次不用让故事就此打住。我很快就要去歌剧院了。我可以把这个故事提升到一个更高的层次。
I can take this to the next logical step-- the step it never gets to, the step you need an opera house for. And it turns out, I actually have a hook-up for the kind of music that Carin is talking about. Some of you know this. I have a cousin. His name is Philip Glass. He has--
我可以把它带到逻辑上的下一步——它从未到达的那一步，那一步正是需要歌剧院才能实现的。结果发现，我正好有卡琳提到的那种音乐的资源。你们中有些人知道。我有个表亲。他叫菲利普·格拉斯（Philip Glass）。他有——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--written a number of minimalist operas. They have been performed here on this very stage since the 1980s-- Einstein on the Beach just this past fall. And so I called Philip, and he sat down to write. And so today, right now, I am pleased to present here on the Brooklyn Academy of Music Opera House stage--
——创作过许多极简主义歌剧。自上世纪80年代以来，它们一直在舞台上演出——就在去年秋天还上演了《海滩上的爱因斯坦》。于是我给菲利普打了电话，他坐下来开始了创作。所以今天，就在现在，我很高兴能在此呈现布鲁克林音乐学院歌剧院的舞台上——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--the world premiere of his latest opera. I am not joking-- this opera is called Help . Commissioned for our program today on the BAM Opera House stage, his work is played by orchestras all over the world, please welcome Philip Glass.
——他最新歌剧的世界首演。我没开玩笑——这部歌剧就叫《救命》。这是为我们今天在BAM歌剧院的节目所委约创作的，他的作品在世界各地的管弦乐团中演出，请欢迎菲利普·格拉斯。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And to perform this with him, Jonathan Dinklage on violin, Emily Brausa on cello, and, of course, the woman this is all about, Carin Gilfry, mezzo-soprano. Carin?
与他同台演出的有小提琴手乔纳森·丁克拉奇、大提琴手艾米莉·布劳萨，当然，还有这一切的主角，女中音歌唱家卡琳·吉尔弗里。卡琳？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
(SINGING) Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help! Help!
（演唱）救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！救命！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Carin Gilfry, with Jonathan Dinklage, Emily Brausa, and Philip Glass.
卡琳·吉尔弗里，与乔纳森·丁克拉奇、艾米莉·布劳萨和菲利普·格拉斯。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Ladies and gentlemen, for decades, the Brooklyn Academy of Music has been a home for all sorts of new kinds of theater and dance and music and opera. And when they invited our program to perform here today, we wanted to live up to that tradition by trying to invent something new.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。女士们先生们，几十年来，布鲁克林音乐学院一直是各种新型戏剧、舞蹈、音乐和歌剧的家园。当他们邀请我们的节目今天在此表演时，我们希望通过尝试发明一些新的东西来不负这一传统。
And so what you're in for today is true stories. It's journalism, like we always do, but presented as radio drama. And we think these are radio dramas like you have never heard before. We have journalism turned into opera, into a full-on Broadway musical. We have journalism turned into a play that is structured like a radio documentary.
所以你们今天将要听到的是真实的故事。这是新闻报道，就像我们一贯所做的那样，但以广播剧的形式呈现。我们认为这些是你们从未听过的广播剧。我们把新闻变成了歌剧，变成了完整的百老汇音乐剧。我们把新闻变成了结构像广播纪录片的戏剧。
The fact is, there are so many ways you can tell a true story. There are so, so many ways. And today, instead of just applying the tools of journalism to everyday stories like we usually do, we try to harness the full power of music and theater.
事实上，讲述真实故事的方法有很多很多种。真的有很多种。今天，我们不再只是像往常一样把新闻工具应用到日常故事中，而是尝试利用音乐和戏剧的全部力量。
Like Carin's story-- we are not done with Carin's story. Sure, you could do it is as a minimalist opera. But what if you wanted to stage it as kind of an old-school opera-opera, the kind that they take you on field trips to when you're a kid. Like, what would that be? I asked Carin in our interview, and she was game to speculate.
就像卡琳的故事——我们还没讲完卡琳的故事。当然，你可以把它做成极简主义歌剧。但如果你想把它排成那种老派的歌剧呢，就是那种你小时候学校组织去看的。那会是什么样？我在采访中问了卡琳，她很乐意猜测。
Oh, I don't know. I mean, as a whole opera? I mean, opera is long. Maybe the elves from the book would come and prance around and sing about the enchanted forest. That was the book I was narrating.
哦，我不知道。我是说，作为一部完整的歌剧？歌剧是很长的。也许书里的精灵会跑出来，唱着关于魔法森林的歌。那正是我在录的那本书。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
(SINGING) We are the elves from Carin's story. We are the elves from Carin's story. We are the elves from Carin's story. We are the elves from Carin's story. We are the elves from Carin's story. We are the elves from Carin's story.
（演唱）我们是卡琳故事里的精灵。我们是卡琳故事里的精灵。我们是卡琳故事里的精灵。我们是卡琳故事里的精灵。我们是卡琳故事里的精灵。我们是卡琳故事里的精灵。
We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves.
我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。
My name is Cheets. I'm Violet . My name is Cheets. I'm Violet.
我叫奇茨。我是维奥莱特。我叫奇茨。我是维奥莱特。
We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves. We are the elves!
我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵。我们是精灵！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Of course, you would need more than elves in this story. Like, also you would want--
当然，故事里不能只有精灵。你还会想要——
The people. The people walking around the closet. The German people. There could be, you know, a "just got to New York" aria sung in German.
那些人。在衣柜周围走动的人。那些德国人。可以有一段“刚到纽约”的咏叹调，用德语唱出来。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
[SINGING IN GERMAN]
[德语演唱]
Actually what they're singing is, we have just arrived. The air is dirty and smoggy.
其实他们唱的是，我们刚到。空气很脏，全是雾霾。
[SINGING IN GERMAN]
[德语演唱]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I don't know if you caught the German there. One of the tourists says, I think someone called for help in German. And the other one says, impossible-- everyone in this country is illiterate.
不知道你们有没有听懂那段德语。其中一个游客说，我觉得有人用德语喊救命。另一个说，不可能——这个国家的人都是文盲。
Then there's the front desk lady-- you know, the one that Carin calls from her iPad.
然后是前台女士——就是卡琳用iPad呼叫的那位。
Right. It could be funny if she was like, oh, my life is so boring. I just answer this phone all day, and people ask for room service. You do a cutaway. I'm stuck in the closet. And finally, this is her big moment, and she doesn't even know it.
没错。如果她唱着“哦，我的生活太无聊了。我整天坐在这接电话，人们只问客房服务。你切个镜头。我困在衣柜里了。最后，这是她的大高潮，她自己却完全不知道。”这会很有趣。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
(SINGING) Oh! It's so boring. It's boring as can be! It's boring to sit behind this desk. It's boring to be me!
（演唱）哦！太无聊了。无聊透顶！坐在这桌子后面太无聊了。做我真是太无聊了！
(SINGING) Hello? Are you there? Can you hear me?
（演唱）喂？你在那儿吗？你能听到我吗？
(SINGING) No one ever notices my radiant complexion. No one ever asks me for anything but directions.
（演唱）从来没人注意到我光彩照人。从来没人问我除了指路以外的事。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Then there's the husband. In this version of the story, we could actually see him out on his audition, belting his heart out, oblivious to the pain that his wife is going through.
然后是丈夫。在这个版本里，我们可以看到他在试镜，放声歌唱，却对妻子的痛苦一无所知。
So maybe we could incorporate some kind of famous baritone aria.
所以也许我们可以加入某种著名的男中音咏叹调。
I wonder, like, what would be the most appropriate and ironic aria for him to be singing.
我在想，他唱什么咏叹调最合适且最讽刺呢。
Oh, I don't know. Something about love, I'm sure. Or something about being a rescuer.
哦，我不知道。一定是关于爱情的。或者关于成为一个救援者的。
We actually talked about what would be best. And we finally settled on a scene from Rigoletto , where the title character who loves his daughter more than anything in the world rages against courtiers who have locked her up in a tiny room. Open up that door, he sings. Open up.
我们讨论过什么最合适。最后选定了《弄臣》中的一段，主角爱他女儿胜过一切，他向把她关在小房间里的廷臣们愤怒咆哮。打开那扇门，他唱道。打开它。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
[SINGING ARIA FROM "RIGOLETTO"]
[演唱《弄臣》咏叹调]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
God, that was great. Carin will be so proud of me.
天哪，太棒了。卡琳会为我感到骄傲的。
Of course, the climax of our opera arrives with the entrance of the housekeeper.
当然，歌剧的高潮随着客房服务员的登场而到来。
What should she be like in the opera version of this story?
在这个歌剧版本里她该是什么样？
Um, gosh. I mean, maybe she just rescues people all day. Maybe somebody's having a baby, and she delivers a baby. And then she cleans up after it.
嗯，天哪。也许她整天都在救人。也许有人要生孩子了，她接生了孩子。然后她清理残局。
Like, she saves a guy who's out on the ledge. She gets him to come inside.
就像她救了一个在窗台上的人。她把他拉回屋里。
Yeah.
对。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
(SINGING) What is it now? You've locked yourself in? I just delivered a baby in room 310, rescued a hostage, extinguished a fire! It's time to retire. But first, this little door's no match for me! One little push, I'll set you free!
（演唱）现在又怎么了？你把自己锁进去了？我刚在310号房接生了一个孩子，救了一个人质，扑灭了一场火灾！我该退休了。但首先，这扇小门难不倒我！轻轻一推，我就让你重获自由！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
(SINGING) I can't believe--
（演唱）我真不敢相信——
(SINGING) She can't believe--
（演唱）她不敢相信——
(SINGING) I am free.
（演唱）我自由了。
(SINGING) She is free.
（演唱）她自由了。
(SINGING) Out of the closet.
（演唱）走出了衣柜。
(SINGING) Out.
（演唱）出去了。
(SINGING) And into the light.
（演唱）走向了光明。
(SINGING) Her clothes are all the same.
（演唱）她的衣服都没变。
(SINGING) I don't get paid enough. I don't get paid enough.
（演唱）我的工资不够。我的工资不够。
(SINGING) Ah--
（演唱）啊——
[GERMAN CONVERSATION]
[德语对话]
[OPERA COUNTERPOINT]
[歌剧对位]
[GERMAN CONVERSATION]
[德语对话]
[OPERA COUNTERPOINT]
[歌剧对位]
Seriously. True story.
说真的。真实故事。
(SINGING) Ah!
（演唱）啊！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Our opera, En Schrank Gefangen, or Trapped in the Closet , was composed by Matt Aucoin, music direction and keyboards by William Hobbs. It featured Rachel Feldsetin, Candice Hoyes and Sarah Craft as elves, Marnie Breckenridge as the front desk, Adrian Rosas as the husband, Jeanine de Bique as the housekeeper, Rod Gilfry, who's actually Karen's dad, as the German tourist with Heather Buck, and mezzo-soprano Carin Gilfry as herself.
我们的歌剧，《困在衣柜里》，由马特·奥科因作曲，威廉·霍布斯担任音乐指导和键盘手。演员包括雷切尔·费尔德斯坦、坎迪斯·霍伊斯和莎拉·克拉夫特饰演精灵，玛妮·布雷肯里奇饰演前台，阿德里安·罗萨斯饰演丈夫，珍妮·德·比克饰演客房服务员，罗德·吉尔弗里（他真的是卡琳的父亲）与希瑟·巴克饰演德国游客，女中音卡琳·吉尔弗里饰演她自己。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Which brings us to act one. Act One, "21 Chump Street, the Musical." I've always wondered what it would mean to try one of our radio stories as a musical. I was taken to so many musicals as a kid. And I think because of that, my basic sense of what makes a satisfying story actually comes from musicals much more than from TV or movies.
接下来进入第一幕。第一幕，“21宗罪，音乐剧”。我一直很好奇如果把我们的广播故事做成音乐剧会是什么样。我小时候看过好多音乐剧。我想正因为如此，我对什么是满意的故事的基本判断力，更多是来自音乐剧，而不是电视或电影。
If you think about, like, the classic old musicals-- Fiddler on the Roof or even A Chorus Line -- it's like, they're funny at the beginning. And then there's something really emotional. And they're about some bigger idea. They take you into this world. I just love that.
如果你想想经典的旧音乐剧——《屋顶上的小提琴手》甚至《歌舞线上》——它们开头很有趣。然后会有一些非常感人的东西。它们关于某种更大的思想。它们把你带进这个世界。我就是喜欢那样。
And so what you're about to hear is our first attempt at a musical based on journalism. Probably 70% to 80% of what you're about to hear is verbatim quotes from interviews. The rest is artistic invention. I'll say that upfront.
所以你们接下来要听到的是我们第一次尝试基于新闻报道创作音乐剧。你们听到的大约70%到80%的内容都是采访的逐字引用。剩下的则是艺术加工。我先声明一下。
It's based on a true story you may remember from our radio program. Back in May, 2011, at a bunch of high schools in Palm Beach County, Florida, a group of young police officers were sent undercover to pose as students. They went to classes. They ate in the cafeteria. They had fake Facebook accounts, of course.
故事基于你们可能在我们广播节目中听过的真实故事。回到2011年5月，在佛罗里达州棕榈滩县的一堆高中里，一群年轻警察被派去卧底扮成学生。他们去上课，在食堂吃饭。当然，他们还有虚假的Facebook账号。
There had been complaints about drugs being sold at these schools. That's what they were there to deal with. And what happened next in this one school was transformed into a musical by a team of people who usually do this on Broadway. Pretty much everybody involved in this, the cast, the chorus, the musicians, the director, Michael Mayer-- all from Broadway. Words and music are by Lin-Manuel Miranda, probably best known--
当时有投诉称这些学校有人卖毒品。这就是他们要处理的问题。在这个学校接下来发生的事情被一群通常在百老汇工作的人改编成了音乐剧。参与其中的每个人，演员、合唱团、音乐家、导演迈克尔·梅尔——全都是百老汇的人。词曲作者是林-曼努埃尔·米兰达，他大概最广为人知——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--probably best known for writing and starring in In the Heights . He will be your narrator.
——他大概因为创作并主演了《身在高地》而最广为人知。他将担任你们的讲述者。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
The plan was called Operation D-minus. And one of the schools included in the plan was Park Vista Community High School, where a kid named Justin Laboy--
该计划被称为“D减行动”。计划涉及的学校之一是公园景观社区高中，那里有个叫贾斯汀·拉博伊的孩子——
(SINGING) That's me.
（演唱）那就是我。
--an 18-year-old honor roll student--
——一个18岁的荣誉学生——
(SINGING) I get straight A's, man.
（演唱）我拿的全是A，伙计。
--was in the last semester of his senior year. Justin could hardly believe his luck, when a very pretty girl showed up.
——当时正处于高三最后一学期。当一个非常漂亮的女孩出现时，贾斯汀简直不敢相信自己的运气。
(SINGING) Naomi!
（演唱）娜奥米！
In not one but two of his classes.
不仅在一门课，而是在两门课上。
(SINGING) Naomi!
（演唱）娜奥米！
She sat in front of him. He switched seats.
她坐在他前面。他换了座位。
(SINGING) Naomi!
（演唱）娜奥米！
The last name she used was--
她用的姓氏是——
(SINGING) Rodriguez.
（演唱）罗德里格斯。
Justin, what drew you to Naomi initially?
贾斯汀，当初是什么吸引了你对娜奥米感兴趣？
(SINGING) Man, she used to fall asleep in class. She was a (SINGING) light-skinneded Puerto Rican-Dominican-- long hair, mature in the body like whoa.
（演唱）伙计，她以前在课上睡觉。她是那种（演唱）浅肤色的波多黎各-多米尼加混血——长头发，身体发育成熟得让人哇哦。
(SINGING) Like, whoa.
（演唱）像，哇哦。
(SINGING) That's not the only reason I liked her, though. She said she moved with her mother to Florida from New York.
（演唱）不过那不是我喜欢她的唯一原因。她说她和妈妈从纽约搬到了佛罗里达。
(SINGING) Where dreams are made.
（演唱）梦想诞生的地方。
(SINGING) Well, so did I. So I said, hi. She seemed mature, and I talked more.
（演唱）嗯，我也是。所以我说，嗨。她看起来很成熟，我就多说了几句。
(SINGING) More, more!
（演唱）更多，更多！
(SINGING) And I was like, what the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）我心想，我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do?
（演唱）我得做点什么？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do?
（演唱）我得做点什么？
(SINGING) Tell me who I gotta be for you to be with me.
（演唱）告诉我我得成为谁，你才能和我在一起。
You told her all this in class?
你在课上对她说了这些？
(SINGING) Well, yeah. I texted her! You know, I was like, (SINGING) what the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）嗯，是的。我发短信给她了！你知道，我当时想，（演唱）我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) L-O-L-O-L-O-L!
（演唱）大笑，大笑，大笑！
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) R-O-F-L-O-L!
（演唱）笑翻，大笑！
(SINGING) Tell me  who I gotta be for you to be with me.
（演唱）告诉我我得成为谁，你才能和我在一起。
(SINGING)  (SINGING) Smiley face.
（演唱）微笑表情。
(SINGING) Yes! (SINGING) Next thing you know, we're texting day and night. I trust her right away.
（演唱）是的！（演唱）接下来你知道的，我们没日没夜地发短信。我立刻就信任她了。
(SINGING) Like, whoa!
（演唱）像，哇哦！
(SINGING) Hey, yo. I never met anyone like her, bro. Yo, she listens to all my problems. I let her copy all my homework. And then I lay it all on the line. And she was like--
（演唱）嘿，伙计。我从没见过像她这样的人，兄弟。她听我倾诉所有的烦恼。我让她抄我所有的作业。然后我全盘托出。她说——
(SINGING) No, no--
（演唱）不，不——
(SINGING) No! She didn't say no exactly. I don't know.
（演唱）不！她并没有完全拒绝。我不知道。
(SINGING) No, no, no!
（演唱）不，不，不！
(SINGING) Yeah, I was surprised. I'm a pretty great guy.
（演唱）是的，我很惊讶。我可是个很棒的家伙。
(SINGING) So? So?
（演唱）那么？那么？
(SINGING) So I decided I needed to step my game up.
（演唱）所以我决定我得提升一下段位。
(SINGING) Oh. Oh. Oh! Oh.
（演唱）哦。哦。哦！哦。
(SINGING) It's too late to be shy. So I got in front of the whole class one day, and I serenaded her. I was like, what the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）害羞已经太晚了。所以我有一天在全班同学面前，为她献唱。我唱道，我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do?
（演唱）我得做点什么？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do?
（演唱）我得做点什么？
(SINGING) Tell me who I gotta be for you to go to prom with me!
（演唱）告诉我我得成为谁，你才愿意和我去参加舞会！
You asked her to the prom?
你邀请她参加舞会了？
(SINGING) Yeah! I danced and everything.
（演唱）是的！我还跳了舞，什么都做了。
(SINGING)  (SINGING) Naomi!
（演唱）娜奥米！
(SINGING) Naomi! I know there's a reason you were transferred here to  me.
（演唱）娜奥米！我知道你转学来我是有原因的。
(SINGING) Naomi!
（演唱）娜奥米！
(SINGING) Naomi! I know there's a reason this isn't luck. It's destiny.
（演唱）娜奥米！我知道这不是运气。这是命运。
(SINGING) Naomi!
（演唱）娜奥米！
(SINGING) Naomi! You know me! Will you go to prom with me?
（演唱）娜奥米！你认识我！你愿意和我一起去参加舞会吗？
(SINGING) I'll think about it.
（演唱）我考虑一下。
(SINGING) She'll think about it. She'll think about it. She'll think about it. She'll think about.
（演唱）她会考虑一下。她会考虑一下。她会考虑一下。她会考虑一下。
(SINGING) She said she'd think about it.
（演唱）她说她会考虑一下。
(SINGING) She'll think about it.
（演唱）她会考虑一下。
(SINGING) Think about it.
（演唱）考虑一下。
(SINGING) She'll think about it.
（演唱）她会考虑一下。
(SINGING) She'll think about it. She'll think about it.
（演唱）她会考虑一下。她会考虑一下。
(SINGING) Yes!
（演唱）是的！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[BELL CHIMING]
[铃声]
(SINGING) I didn't say yes. I didn't say I'll think about it. I can't tell you my real name, but yes, I can confirm that I did get asked to the prom.
（演唱）我没说愿意。我没说我会考虑。我不能告诉你我的真实姓名，但是的，我可以确认我确实被邀请去参加舞会了。
The undercover officer who posed as Naomi is 25 years old, a new recruit with the Palm Beach Police Force.
扮成娜奥米的卧底警察今年25岁，是棕榈滩警察局的一名新兵。
(SINGING) My assignment-- to pose as a senior and find out who's buying, who's selling. Mostly pills and weed. You would not believe how easy it is to get pills and weed.
（演唱）我的任务——冒充高中生，查出谁在买，谁在卖。主要是药片和大麻。你不会相信获取药片和大麻有多容易。
What's the hardest part?
最难的部分是什么？
The cafeteria. Imagine hundreds of teenagers yelling and running full speed. And the lack of deodorant. Let's just say I would drink at the end of the day. Seriously, these kids need to learn there are consequences in life. If I'm doing my job and I'm doing it right, I am making life safer one school at a time.
食堂。想象一下几百个青少年在尖叫，全速奔跑。还有那股狐臭味。只能说，每天结束时我都要喝上一杯。说真的，这些孩子需要明白生活是有后果的。如果我在做我的工作，而且做得对，我是在让学校变得更安全。
So he asked you to prom?
所以他邀请你去舞会了？
(SINGING) Right. (SINGING) I gave every excuse. I said it's too expensive, which is totally true, by the way. I told him, look, I'm just a transfer. I wouldn't feel comfortable with all your friends. And it's true you make friends on the job. Then it ends. You meet kids  who are sensitive, smart, and defenseless. Those are the ones you remember, the ones that you think about after you're gone.
（演唱）对。（演唱）我给了各种借口。我说这太贵了，顺便说一句，这是事实。我告诉他，看，我只是个转校生。和你的朋友们在一起我会觉得不舒服。这也是真的，你在工作时会交到朋友。然后一切就结束了。你会遇到敏感、聪明、无助的孩子。那些是你记住的，那些是你离开后还会挂念的人。
Seriously, these kids need to learn there are consequences in life. If I'm doing my job and I'm doing it right, I am making life safer one school at a time.
说真的，这些孩子需要明白生活是有后果的。如果我在做我的工作，而且做得对，我是在让学校变得更安全。
Meanwhile--
同时——
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do to be with you?
（演唱）我得做点什么才能和你在一起？
(SINGING) What the heck I gotta do?
（演唱）我得做点什么？
(SINGING) Tell me who I gotta be for you to be with me.
（演唱）告诉我我得成为谁，你才能和我在一起。
(SINGING) Do you smoke?
（演唱）你抽大麻吗？
What?
什么？
(SINGING) Do you smoke weed?
（演唱）你抽大麻吗？
(SINGING) No, I don't. But if that's what you need, I can find some for you. I can be your  supply.
（演唱）不，我不抽。但如果你需要，我可以为你找点。我可以成为你的供货人。
(SINGING) You would do that for me?
（演唱）你愿意为我这样做？
(SINGING) I can be your guy. Oh, yes!
（演唱）我可以成为你的那个人。哦，太棒了！
(SINGING) Seriously, these kids need to learn there are consequences in life.
（演唱）说真的，这些孩子需要明白生活是有后果的。
(SINGING) I'll get whatever you need!
（演唱）我会弄到你需要的任何东西！
(SINGING) If I'm doing my job and I'm doing it right, I am making life safer one school at a time.
（演唱）如果我在做我的工作，而且做得对，我是在让学校变得更安全。
Listen, I'm not a drug dealer. So it's not like she asked me this day, and I got it for her the very next day. It took me a while, you know? So I mean, I'm trying to get it, and I can't get it.
听着，我不是毒贩。所以不是她那天问我，我第二天就给她弄到了。花了我一段时间，你知道吗？我是说，我在试图弄到它，但我弄不到。
What are you thinking as you're trying to get this pot to sell her?
你在试图为她弄大麻时在想什么？
I'm thinking, what the heck am I doing? I never done this before. So I'm, you know-- I'm really scared and skeptical at the same point.
我在想，我到底在干什么？我从来没做过这种事。所以我——我当时既害怕又怀疑。
What did you end up doing?
你最后怎么做的？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
I called a cousin who called a cousin who called his friend, who called a couple dozen cousins, 'cause it doesn't  end.
我给表亲打电话，他给表亲打电话，又打了给他朋友，又打给几十个表亲，因为这没完没了。
My cousin Justin's looking for a little something-something for a certain someone, some girl he wants to be touching.
我表弟贾斯汀在为某个人找点东西，某个他想追求的女孩。
(SINGING) Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something.
（演唱）每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。
We were just discussing our cousin Justin. Wasn't Justin the cousin who just made the honor roll, got the colleges buzzin'?
我们刚才在讨论表弟贾斯汀。贾斯汀不就是那个刚拿到荣誉学生，让大学都抢着要的表亲吗？
Are we close to  our cousin Justin? Are we supposed to trust him?
我们和表弟贾斯汀亲近吗？我们应该信任他吗？
Are we thugs to our cousin Justin? We don't sell drugs, man.
我们对表弟贾斯汀来说是暴徒吗？我们不卖毒品，伙计。
(SINGING) Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something.
（演唱）每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。
Did you get it yet?
你弄到了吗？
No, I'm about to get it.
没，马上就弄到了。
Is your dealer a student?
你的供货商是学生吗？
I got you, girl. Don't sweat it.
搞定了，女孩。别担心。
Let me know  when you got it.
弄到的时候告诉我。
As soon as I can.
我会尽快。
I'll find a way to repay you, Justin.
我会找到办法报答你的，贾斯汀。
Oh, man!
哦，天哪！
Yo, what is up with this fussin'? This isn't up for discussion. This is our cousin coming to us. He's our blood, and we love him.
嘿，吵什么吵？这没什么可讨论的。这是我们的表亲来找我们。他是我们的血亲，我们爱他。
Ah, look at Justin. He's blushing.
啊，看贾斯汀。他在脸红。
Our little Justin is crushing.
我们的小贾斯汀在恋爱呢。
Sorry for rushing to judgement.
抱歉之前那么快下判断。
Why should we get you these drugs?
为什么要帮你弄毒品？
(SINGING) Love!
（演唱）爱！
What?
什么？
(SINGING) Only if you believe in love. Love!
（演唱）只有如果你相信爱。爱！
(SINGING) Love! Only if you believe in love.
（演唱）爱！只有如果你相信爱。
Get him the stuff.
给他弄点东西。
I hand my cousin 25 ducats. I'm sweating buckets. He hands me a sandwich bag with some little green nuggets. I got it for you.
我给了表亲25个杜卡特。我冷汗直流。他给了我一个塑料袋，里面装了点小绿块。我为你弄到了。
X-O. Cool.
吻和拥抱。酷。
You want it now?
你现在就要吗？
See you at school.
学校见。
(SINGING) Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something.
（演唱）每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。
(SINGING) Love!
（演唱）爱！
(SINGING) Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin--
（演唱）每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个——
(SINGING) Only if you believe in love!
（演唱）只有如果你相信爱！
(SINGING) --who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something. Everybody's got a cousin who can hook them up with something.
（演唱）——能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。每个人都有个能帮你弄到东西的表亲。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Now, according to the police, Justin is a drug dealer. Maybe Justin didn't know where to get drugs. Maybe he did. What we know is this. The next day, Justin brought a rolled-up baggie of marijuana to school for Naomi.
根据警方的说法，贾斯汀是一名毒贩。也许贾斯汀不知道从哪里买毒品。也许他知道。我们所知道的是。第二天，贾斯汀带着一小袋卷好的大麻到学校给娜奥米。
And I was like, oh my god, I'm actually about to do this. So we was in class, and I sat down right next to her. And she was like--
我当时心想，哦天哪，我真的要干这种事了。我们在教室里，我坐在她旁边。她说——
Justin, do you have it?
贾斯汀，你弄到了吗？
Yeah, I do. And I was like, you know what? We're going to wait for a few. Because I didn't want to be like, oh hey, and just slide it in her hand or whatever. So we waited.
是的。我当时心想，你知道吗？我们要等一会儿。因为我不想表现得像，哦嘿，然后直接塞进她手里什么的。所以我们等了等。
[WOOD BLOCKS TICK-TOCKING]
[木鱼滴答声]
And she was like--
她说——
OK, put it in my purse.
好了，放进我包里。
So I slid it right in there. And then she was like--
于是我就塞进去了。然后她说——
OK, here. Take the money. Justin, take the money.
好了，拿着。拿钱。贾斯汀，拿着钱。
(SINGING) I don't want your money. I got this just for you. Keep your money. There's nothing I won't do for you. I'll come through for you every time-- "Justin" time.
（演唱）我不要你的钱。我这纯粹是为了你。留着你的钱吧。没什么是我不会为你做的。我会为你挺身而出，每次都是——“贾斯汀”时间。
(SINGING) Justin, listen. Please, just take the money.
（演唱）贾斯汀，听着。求你了，拿着钱。
(SINGING) Naomi, I know there's a reason you were transferred here.
（演唱）娜奥米，我知道你转学来是有原因的。
(SINGING) You're making me feel guilty. Take the money.
（演唱）你让我感到内疚。拿着钱。
(SINGING) Naomi, I know there's a reason. This isn't luck. It's destiny.
（演唱）娜奥米，我知道是有原因的。这不是运气。这是命运。
(SINGING) You really did come through for me.
（演唱）你真的为了我挺身而出了。
(SINGING) Naomi, you know me.
（演唱）娜奥米，你认识我。
(SINGING) There's only one last thing you need to do for me.
（演唱）你最后只需要为我做一件事。
(SINGING) I will be there just in time. Every time.
（演唱）我会准时赶到。每次都是。
(SINGING) Take the money. Take the money.
（演唱）拿着钱。拿着钱。
(SINGING) Anytime.
（演唱）任何时候。
(SINGING) Take the money.
（演唱）拿着钱。
(SINGING) Naomi.
（演唱）娜奥米。
(SINGING) I don't want your money.
（演唱）我不要你的钱。
(SINGING) The teacher's coming. Take  this money, Justin.
（演唱）老师来了。拿着这钱，贾斯汀。
(SINGING) I got this just for you.
（演唱）我这纯粹是为了你。
(SINGING) Naomi.
（演唱）娜奥米。
(SINGING) Keep your money.
（演唱）留着你的钱。
(SINGING) We aren't done. Please take this money, Justin.
（演唱）我们还没完。请拿着这钱，贾斯汀。
(SINGING) Naomi.
（演唱）娜奥米。
(SINGING) I'll come through for you.
（演唱）我会为你挺身而出。
(SINGING) Naomi.
（演唱）娜奥米。
(SINGING) Take the money.
（演唱）拿着钱。
(SINGING) Every time. Anytime.
（演唱）每次都是。任何时候。
(SINGING) Take the money. Take this money, Justin.
（演唱）拿着钱。拿着这钱，贾斯汀。
(SINGING) Just in time.
（演唱）准时。
Justin would later find out it's a felony in Florida to sell marijuana. And the penalty is even harsher for selling it on school property. By taking the money, Justin had made an irreversibly bad decision. And since he was over 18, he was legally an adult when he made it.
贾斯汀后来发现，在佛罗里达州销售大麻是重罪。在校内销售处罚更重。通过收钱，贾斯汀做出了一个无法挽回的错误决定。而且因为他已年满18岁，他在法律上是个成年人。
(SINGING) Seriously, these kids need to learn there are consequences in life. I am doing my job. I am doing it right. I am making life safe for one school at a time.
（演唱）说真的，这些孩子需要明白生活是有后果的。我在做我的工作。我是在做对的事。我是在让学校变得更安全。
In May, the police arrested 31 students at several schools. Justin was one of them.
五月，警方在几所学校逮捕了31名学生。贾斯汀就是其中之一。
[SIRENS]
[警笛声]
Freeze! You have the right to  remain silent.
不许动！你有权保持沉默。
(SINGING) Everybody who sold drugs to undercover cops is busted. Everybody who sold drugs to undercover cops is busted. Everybody who sold drugs to undercover cops is busted. Everybody who sold drugs to undercover cops is busted.
（演唱）每个卖毒品给卧底警察的都被捕了。每个卖毒品给卧底警察的都被捕了。每个卖毒品给卧底警察的都被捕了。每个卖毒品给卧底警察的都被捕了。
He spends a week in jail wondering what would happen next.
他在监狱里待了一周，琢磨着接下来会发生什么。
It's your word against hers. The cops have every text. The cops have every text. The cops have every text. (SINGING) Don't worry, girl. I got the stuff. I got you.
这是你和她各执一词。警察有所有的短信。警察有所有的短信。警察有所有的短信。（演唱）别担心，女孩。我弄到了货。我搞定了。
He knew he'd lose in court. He had to take a plea.
他知道自己在法庭上会输。他必须认罪。
Three years' probation. I plead guilty to the felony.
三年缓刑。我对重罪指控认罪。
What? A felony? A nickel bag's a felony? What? (SINGING) Justin, say goodbye to college. They got you.
什么？重罪？一小袋大麻就是重罪？什么？（演唱）贾斯汀，跟大学说再见吧。他们抓到你了。
These kids need to wake up. I don't want to go too much into it, but drugs hit really close to home for me. I saw the effects growing up of cocaine, marijuana, ecstasy.
这些孩子需要醒醒了。我不愿多说，但毒品问题对我来说非常贴近。我成长过程中目睹了可卡因、大麻、摇头丸带来的后果。
With family members?
是家人吗？
(SINGING) Yes. I've seen what it can do to a family. That's all I want to say about it.
（演唱）是的。我见过它能对一个家庭造成什么影响。我想说的就这么多。
Do you wish someone like you had done this type of work?
你希望有人像你一样做这种工作吗？
Yes. And I hope someone like me keeps doing it. Still, (SINGING) there are  kids you remember, the ones that you think about after you're gone.
是的。我希望有人像我一样继续做下去。尽管如此，（演唱）总有一些孩子让你记住，那些你离开后还会挂念的人。
During the week he spent in jail, Justin couldn't help but think about Naomi.
在监狱里的那周，贾斯汀忍不住想念娜奥米。
(SINGING) She was a light-skinneded Puerto Rican-Dominican, long hair, mature in the body like whoa. That's not the only reason I liked her, though. Yo, if it had been a guy that came up to me asking me for drugs, I would have said no. I would have said, get out of my face. I don't hang out with people like that. It's because it was her.
（演唱）她是那种浅肤色的波多黎各-多米尼加混血，长头发，身体发育成熟得让人哇哦。不过那不是我喜欢她的唯一原因。嘿，如果是个男的跑来找我买毒品，我会拒绝的。我会说，滚远点。我不和那种人混在一起。正是因为她是她。
Have you talked to her since all of this happened?
这一切发生后你和她谈过吗？
Well, no. I would love to. I would love to have that conversation.
嗯，没有。我很想。我很想有那样的对话。
What do you think you would say?
你觉得你会说什么？
(SINGING) I would say, what the heck did you do? What the heck did you do? Naomi? What the heck did you do?
（演唱）我会说，你到底干了什么？你到底干了什么？娜奥米？你到底干了什么？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Our cast, Lindsay Mendez as Naomi, Anthony Ramos as Justin. The chorus, Alex Boniello, Gerard Canonico, and Antwuan Holley. Our narrator, Lin-Manuel Miranda, who also wrote the words and composed the music. The musicians, Music Director Ben Cohn, Sean McDaniel, Mark Vanderpoel, David Cinquegrana Jonathan Dinklage, Emily Brausa, with Scott Wasserman.
我们的演员阵容，琳赛·门德斯饰演娜奥米，安东尼·拉莫斯饰演贾斯汀。合唱团，亚历克斯·博尼洛、杰拉德·卡诺尼科和安特旺·霍利。我们的讲述者，林-曼努埃尔·米兰达，他同时也作词作曲。音乐家们，音乐总监本·科恩，肖恩·麦克丹尼尔，马克·范德波尔，大卫·辛奎格拉纳，乔纳森·丁克拉奇，艾米莉·布劳萨，以及斯科特·瓦瑟曼。
To everybody who was actually listening to this right now on the radio-- or podcast, I should say-- the staging of this story was like a 14-minute nonstop dance number from start to finish, choreographed by Lorin Latarro, costumes, sets. Lots of laughs--
对现在正在广播里——或者说播客里听着这一切的所有人，这个故事的舞台排演是一场14分钟不停歇的舞蹈，由洛林·拉塔罗编舞，服装、布景。很多笑声——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Lots of laughs in today's show are visual things that you are not seeing because you're hearing it only. If you would like to see what you are missing, you can do that. You can do that right this second. You can download video of this entire show that we're doing today at the Brooklyn Academy of Music. Go to our website, thisamericanlife.org. Like Beyonce, we are dropping the album and all the videos on the same day.
今天的节目里有很多笑点是视觉上的，你们因为只听声音所以看不到。如果你想看看你错过了什么，你可以做到。你现在就可以做到。你可以下载我们今天在布鲁克林音乐学院演出的整个节目的视频。去我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。就像碧昂丝一样，我们选择在同一天放出专辑和所有视频。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
She's a role model. We also have links to where you can get the official cast album recording of "21 Chump Street, the Musical."
她是榜样。我们还有链接，你可以买到“21宗罪，音乐剧”的正式演员版专辑。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Possibly the shortest cast album recording in Broadway history. Coming up, Mike Birbiglia and the secret jokes a professional comedian usually only shares at home. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
这可能是百老汇史上最短的演员版专辑录音。接下来，迈克·比比利亚将带来职业喜剧演员通常只在家里分享的秘密笑话。一分钟后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, from the stage of the Brooklyn Academy of Music in Brooklyn, New York City, the radio drama episode.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，带来关于这个主题的不同故事。今天，在纽约市布鲁克林的布鲁克林音乐学院舞台上，是广播剧集。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
We have journalism, memoir, true stories ed as radio drama. We have arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, "Of Mice and Men." So this next bit of radio drama is not an experiment for us like a musical or an opera. We thought it would be smart to have one story in today's show where we know what we're doing. A type of radio drama we actually bring you now and then on the program, a true story told on stage by the person that it actually happened to. Please welcome comedian Mike Birbiglia.
我们有新闻、回忆录、以广播剧形式呈现的真实故事。我们的节目进入了第二幕。第二幕，“人鼠之间”。这个广播剧对我们来说不像音乐剧或歌剧那样是个实验。我们觉得今天节目里放一个我们擅长的故事会很明智。这是我们节目中偶尔会带给你们的一种广播剧，由当事人亲口在舞台上讲述的真实故事。请欢迎喜剧演员迈克·比比利亚。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Wow. It's pretty easy following a musical.
哇。在音乐剧之后上场还真容易。
I, uh-- I think that my favorite thing about being married is actually that you can share jokes with your wife or husband that are funny to you and that person and no one else other than maybe your cat. Because when you have a cat, your barometer for humor, poof, out the window.
我，呃——我觉得婚姻里我最喜欢的一点是，你可以和妻子或丈夫分享只有你和那个人觉得好笑的笑话，除了你们的猫以外谁也听不懂。因为当你养了猫，你的幽默准绳，呼，就彻底没影了。
Last summer, my wife and I went on a trip to Massachusetts. And I called it Cats-achusetts-- which is not funny, but in our house was the joke of the year. I was like, we're going to Cats-achusetts. My life is like, ahh! I was like, ahh! Our cat was like, ahh!
去年夏天，我和我妻子去马萨诸塞州旅游。我把它叫做“猫萨诸塞州”——这其实不好笑，但在我们家成了年度笑话。我说，我们要去“猫萨诸塞州”。我妻子说，啊！我说，啊！我们的猫说，啊！
Everyone loves a good pun when you have a cat. And so we drive to Cats-achusetts. And when we arrive, my wife has a headache. And she asks me if I'll acclimate Ivan-- that's our cat-- to the bedroom, because you can't just put an indoor cat into a house, because he'll explode.
当你养猫时，每个人都喜欢好双关语。于是我们驱车前往“猫萨诸塞州”。我们到达时，我妻子头痛。她让我带伊万——那是我们的猫——去适应卧室，因为你不能直接把室内猫放进屋子里，否则它会爆炸。
And so I bring him in the bedroom. But I'm so tired from the drive that I fall asleep, which is the only thing you cannot do when acclimating an indoor cat to a house. And so I wake up an hour later. Ivan is gone. He got out.
于是我把它带进卧室。但我开车累坏了，于是睡着了，这正是让室内猫适应环境时绝对不能做的事。一小时后我醒了。伊万不见了。它溜出去了。
And so now I'm running around the house. I'm like, my cat's going to explode. I wake up my wife. I was like, Clo-- her name's Jen-- I say, Mr. Fantastic is gone-- his name's Ivan. And Clo gave me a look that I can only describe as "divorce eyes."
于是我满屋子跑。心想，我的猫要爆炸了。我叫醒我妻子。我说，克洛——她叫简——我说，大人物不见了——它叫伊万。克洛给了我一个我只能描述为“离婚眼神”的眼神。
Because before that, point I was convinced that we would be married forever. And then once I saw the divorce eyes, I was like, oh, I guess this could end. And if it ended, it would look a lot like that.
因为在那之前，我一直确信我们会永远在一起。但一旦我看到了离婚眼神，我就想，哦，我想这事儿要完了。如果它结束了，看起来肯定像那样。
And so now the two of us are running around the house. I'm like, my marriage is falling apart. My cat's going to explode. And we find Ivan, but we had another major problem in the house, which is that there were mice in the house.
于是我们俩在房子里跑来跑去。我心想，我的婚姻要完了。我的猫要爆炸了。我们找到了伊万，但房子里还有一个大问题，那就是有老鼠。
It was actually worse than that, because they were parasitic mice. They have what's called toxoplasmosis, which means they have a-- yeah, you might know what this is. They have a parasite in them, and as a result they're unafraid of cats, and they're unafraid of people.
其实更糟糕，因为它们是寄生虫老鼠。它们患有弓形虫病，这意味着它们有——是的，你们可能知道这是什么。它们体内有寄生虫，所以它们不怕猫，也不怕人。
And the way we discovered this was that my wife was watching TV, and she looked next to her. And there was a mouse. And he was watching TV also. And she screamed!
我们发现这一点是因为我妻子在看电视，她看了看旁边。那里有一只老鼠。它也在看电视。她尖叫起来！
And he just looked up at her like Stuart Little-- like, hey, what's going on? I don't like this show either. I don't know why all those women would want to marry that one guy.
它抬头看着她，就像《精灵鼠小弟》一样——像，嘿，怎么了？我也不喜欢这个节目。我不知道为什么那些女人都想嫁给那个男的。
And then she pushed him off the couch. And he didn't even run away. He didn't even scurry, which is a verb invented for mice. He just walked into the kitchen, like a roommate-- like, fine! I'll go in the other room! I just think you're overreacting.
然后她把它推下沙发。它甚至没跑。它甚至没溜，而“溜”这个词就是为老鼠发明的。它只是走进厨房，就像个室友一样——行吧！我去另一个房间！我觉得你反应过度了。
And then he did a confessional into the Mouse Cam in the kitchen. He was like, I'm not here to make friends. I'm here to win. I was here before they came. I'll be here when they're gone. I'm a mouse.
然后它对着厨房里的“老鼠摄像头”说了句心里话。它说，我不是来交朋友的。我是来赢的。在他们来之前我就在这儿了。他们走了之后我还会在这儿。我是老鼠。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
That's from "Real Mouse-wives of Cats-achusetts." That night, I'm sound asleep, and my wife wakes me up by grabbing my face. She says, Mo-- my name's Mike-- Mr. Fantastic found the mouse. You need to get the mouse.
那是来自《猫萨诸塞州的真实老鼠主妇》。那天晚上，我睡得很死，我妻子抓着我的脸把我弄醒。她说，莫——我叫迈克——大人物找到老鼠了。你得去抓老鼠。
And I sit up, and I say Clo, we have a cat. We do everything for the cat. We gave him food. We give him an apartment that he thinks is the world. We set aside an area in the apartment for him to poop in that we clean more often than the area where we poop.
我坐起来，说克洛，我们养了猫。我们为猫做了一切。我们给它食物。我们给它一个它认为就是全世界的公寓。我们专门在公寓里划出一块地方让它拉屎，我们清理那个地方的次数比清理我们自己拉屎的地方还勤。
We have a gentleman's agreement that in the unlikely event that a mouse should walk in that door (A LA MARLON BRANDO) that he will kill that mouse and we will never speak of that mouse again. And he will be protected. (NORMAL VOICE) That's from "Cat-father."
我们有个君子协定，万一老鼠从门里走进来（模仿马龙·白兰度），它会杀掉那只老鼠，我们绝不再提那只老鼠。它会被保护。（正常嗓音）那来自《猫父》。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
My wife says, Mo, get the mouse. And I sit up, and I see what may be the strangest tableau I will ever witness in my entire life. Ivan's smacking the mouse. The mouse flies in the air, lands, gets up, walks back towards Ivan.
我妻子说，莫，去抓老鼠。我坐起来，看到了我一生中见过的最奇特的场景。伊万在拍打老鼠。老鼠飞到空中，落地，爬起来，又走向伊万。
Ivan smacks the mouse, flies in the air, lands, gets up, walks back towards Ivan. Ivan is thrilled! His toy is alive!
伊万拍打老鼠，它又飞到空中，落地，爬起来，又走向伊万。伊万兴奋极了！它的玩具居然是活的！
I have a serious sleepwalking disorder. So as I am watching this, I'm not even really sure it's happening. I'm thinking, I've had this dream before.
我有严重的梦游症。所以看着这一幕，我甚至不确定这是否真的发生。我想，我以前做过这个梦。
My wife says, Mo, get the mouse. And she hands me a cup.
我妻子说，莫，去抓老鼠。她递给我一个杯子。
I sit up. I walk towards the mouse. And the mouse walks towards me. I put the cup over the mouse. I put a magazine under the cup. I take the cup into the backyard, and I put the mouse into the forest, where I can only assume that he walked into the mouth of a wolf.
我坐起来。我走向老鼠。老鼠也走向我。我用杯子扣住老鼠。我在杯子下塞了本杂志。我把杯子拿到后院，把老鼠放进了森林，我只能假设它走进了一匹狼的嘴里。
And from that day forward, we have called it Mouse-achusetts.
从那天起，我们把它叫做“鼠萨诸塞州”。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I want to point out something really special that happened there at the end. A few minutes ago, I prefaced this story with a Massachusetts-based pun, Cats-achusetts, which we all agreed as a group is not funny.
我想指出最后发生的一件非常特别的事情。几分钟前，我用基于马萨诸塞州的双关语“猫萨诸塞州”引出了这个故事，我们作为一个群体都同意那不好笑。
Just moments ago, I concluded the story with another Massachusetts-based pun that was nearly identical. And that was Mouse-achusetts. And we applauded.
刚才，我用另一个几乎一模一样的基于马萨诸塞州的双关语结束了故事。那就是“鼠萨诸塞州”。而我们鼓掌了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Which means, in a way, it's like we're married.
这意味着，某种程度上，这就像我们结婚了一样。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Mike Birbiglia. He's on his hundred-city "Thank God for Jokes" tour, which, Chicagolandians, comes to the Chicago Theater in September. To everybody hearing us on the radio, there was a person in a mouse costume on roller skates in that story doing some funny stuff. To see the video of this entire show so you understand what people are laughing at-- you will not be sorry-- thisamericanlife.org.
迈克·比比利亚。他正在进行百城巡演“感谢上帝有笑话”，芝加哥地区的听众们，九月会来到芝加哥剧院。对于所有在广播里听到的人，那个故事里有一个穿着老鼠戏服溜旱冰的人做了些有趣的事。想看整个节目的视频以便理解人们在笑什么——你不会后悔的——thisamericanlife.org。
We have arrived at act three of our show. Act Three, "How do you Slow this Thing Down?"
我们的节目进入了第三幕。第三幕，“怎么减慢这东西的速度？”
So this story is a follow up to a story that we ran a couple of years ago, which was a full episode of our show about one of our contributors, Josh Bearman, and his family. The set-up is that Josh's parents got divorced when he was very young. And he and his brother Ethan grew up with their dad, who's a physicist, out in suburban Los Angeles.
这个故事是我们几年前播出的一个故事的后续，那曾是我们节目的一整期，关于我们的贡献者乔希·贝尔曼和他的家人。背景是乔希的父母在他很小时就离婚了。他和弟弟伊森跟着身为物理学家的父亲在洛杉矶郊区长大。
Josh's mom and his half-brother David lived very differently. They drifted around. They ended up in Florida. They were barely keeping it together. Josh's mom was an alcoholic. David was an aspiring rapper getting acquainted with the court system
乔希的母亲和同母异父的弟弟大卫生活方式截然不同。他们四处漂泊。最后到了佛罗里达。他们几乎难以维持生计。乔希的母亲酗酒。大卫是个想当说唱歌手的人，和法院系统纠缠不清。
Together they lived in this tiny condo in a retirement community in West Palm Beach called Century Village, where they did not belong. They were not retirees. And they would get into various kinds of jams and crises. And Josh would have to fly to Florida to try to help. He ended up spending a lot of time there.
他们住在一起，在西棕榈滩一个叫世纪村的退休社区里的一个小公寓里，他们本不属于那里。他们不是退休人员。他们会陷入各种麻烦和危机中。乔希不得不飞到佛罗里达去帮忙。他最终在那里花了很多时间。
What you are about to hear is an experiment at creating a radio drama which has exactly the same structure as one of the documentary stories on our show. And so what's going to happen is the real Josh Bearman is going to narrate. And then instead of going to, like, quotes on tape or things like that, we have actors performing scenes that really happened. All of this really happened. In those scenes, Josh is played by Josh Hamilton. His brother David is played by James Ransone.
你们接下来要听到的是一个实验，旨在创作一个结构与我们节目纪录片故事完全一样的广播剧。接下来，真正的乔希·贝尔曼将担任讲述者。然后，不再是去采访录音什么的，我们有演员来表演真实发生过的场景。这一切都是真实发生的。在那些场景里，乔希由乔希·汉密尔顿饰演。他的弟弟大卫由詹姆斯·兰索恩饰演。
The story begins last year when real-life Josh found himself back in Florida with his two brothers.
故事开始于去年，现实生活中的乔希发现自己又回到了佛罗里达，和他的两个兄弟在一起。
My mother's been in the hospital so much by now she's figured out how to direct the paramedics, like emergency chauffeurs or something, to all of the best facilities. Her room at Wellington Regional is big and bright. It's a corner room with big windows and a nice view. Although she can't see it, because right now she's connected to state-of-the-art equipment behind a curtain.
我母亲住院次数太多了，她已经学会了像指挥出租车司机一样指挥医护人员把她送到最好的设施里。她在惠灵顿地区医院的房间很大很明亮。这是一个带大窗户和美景的角房。虽然她看不见，因为她现在正被帘子后面最先进的设备连着。
[SOUNDS OF MEDICAL EQUIPMENT]
[医疗设备的声音]
When I walk in, my brother David is there already.
当我走进去时，我弟弟大卫已经在那里了。
Hey, man. Oh, this whole thing was like a fucked-up remix of "The Night Before Christmas," because it was the night before Christmas.
嘿，伙计。哦，这整件事就像“圣诞前夜”的混乱重制版，因为它确实是圣诞前夜。
Is this story gonna be in rhyme, or--
这故事是要押韵吗，还是——
Shut up.
闭嘴。
David, what happened?
大卫，发生了什么？
You know how she gets around the holidays. I mean, I thought that you and Ethan were going to bring her out to California.
你知道她在节日期间是什么样。我是说，我以为你和伊森会把她带到加利福尼亚去。
Oh, man. I don't know why we didn't. I think it was Ethan's schedule. Or we probably just didn't try hard enough.
哦，天哪。我不知道为什么我们没去。我觉得是因为伊森的时间表。或者我们可能只是没够努力。
Nah, nah. I mean, you never know when she's going to get all twisted like that. And I wasn't even really around anyway.
不，不。我是说，你永远不知道她什么时候会变得那么扭曲。而且我那时甚至根本不在身边。
Where were you?
你在哪儿？
I was with this girl from school, this girl Tasha. And I went over to her house early on Christmas Eve, because they were having turkey dinner and everything-- you know, like a normal family.
我和学校的一个女孩在一起，那个叫塔莎的女孩。平安夜那天我很早就去了她家，因为他们有火鸡晚餐什么的——你知道，就像正常家庭一样。
I mean, I had to get out of Century Village. I was cooped up in there with Mom, and she was driving me crazy. So anyway, I'm at Tasha's. And Mom calls, and she sounds all drunk, right? And she's like, something happened to the car.
我是说，我得离开世纪村。我和妈一起关在那里，她快把我逼疯了。总之，我在塔莎家。妈打电话来了，听起来喝得很醉，对吧？她说，车子出事了。
Something hap-- what kind of something?
出事了——什么样的出事？
I don't know! That's what I said!
我不知道！我就是这么说的！
That's like something you would tell me.
那听起来像你会告诉我的事。
I know. And now I know how you feel. Well, whatever happened, the car got stuck, right? And I didn't have any way to get to her.
我知道。现在我知道你的感受了。总之，车被困住了，对吧？我没法过去找她。
So how did she get home?
那她是怎么回家的？
I think Peggy picked her up. And by the time I got back to the condo the next day, she was-- she was pretty deep in it. But it didn't seem like that big of a deal really. And then she woke up, and she was short of breath, so I was like--
我想是佩吉接她的。等我第二天回到公寓时，她——她已经陷得很深了。但看起来确实没那么严重。然后她醒了，呼吸急促，所以我当时想——
Wait, wait, wait. For how long?
等等，等等。有多久了？
Tuesday, so for, like, a day.
周二，所以差不多一天了。
And you didn't call me sooner?
你怎么没早点给我打电话？
Dude, she's done this shit, like, a million times. I mean, she wasn't even that worried about it. And she didn't want me to ride in the ambulance with her. She was like, I'll see you later tonight, Dave.
伙计，她这种破事干过一百万次了。我是说，她甚至都不怎么担心。而且她不想让我坐救护车跟她一起去。她说，回头见，戴夫。
Hi, I'm Dr. Snyder. Are-- are you the older brother?
嗨，我是斯奈德医生。你——你是哥哥吗？
Yes.
是的。
You have the medical power of attorney?
你有医疗授权书吗？
Yes.
是的。
Good. And who's Ethan?
好的。那伊森是谁？
Our other brother. He's also coming from California.
我们的另一个弟弟。他也正从加利福尼亚赶来。
He has the medical power of attorney?
他有医疗授权书吗？
Yes.
是的。
Not him?
不是你？
No.
不是。
OK. Oh, uh, did your mother go to Cornell?
好的。哦，呃，你母亲去过康奈尔大学吗？
Yes, why?
是的，怎么了？
She told us.
她是这么说的。
What else did she say?
她还说什么了？
That she does not consume alcohol.
她说她不喝酒。
Those were her last words before going under. Soon enough, withdrawal told a very different story. The first time this happened was five years ago, when David called and told me he had to remit himself to the local sheriff's office for, quote, "just a quick jail sentence." Oh, and Mom's in the hospital.
这是她在进入麻醉状态前说的最后的话。很快，戒断反应就揭示了完全不同的真相。这事第一次发生是在五年前，当时大卫打电话告诉我，他不得不向当地治安官办公室自首，接受一个“快速的短刑期”。哦，而且妈在医院。
So I flew to Florida that next day and went straight to the ICU.
所以第二天我就飞到佛罗里达，直接去了ICU。
[SOUND OF AIRPLANE FLYING OVERHEAD]
[头顶飞机的声音]
And here's what happened that time.
那次发生的事是这样的。
Well, looks like she'll never be the same again.
好吧，看起来她永远恢复不了了。
What, are you the neurologist?
什么，你是神经科医生？
Oh, I see we have a savvy medical consumer here. No. It's 2:00 AM. I'm just the guy on rotation. So she scored low on the GOAT test, which measures brain function. She got a 62-- probably permanently impaired.
哦，我看到这儿有个精明的医疗消费者。不是。现在是凌晨2点。我只是轮班的医生。她GOAT测试分数很低，那个测试是衡量大脑功能的。她得了62分——可能永久性受损。
62? Out of what?
62？总分多少？
Out of 100.
100。
Although no one ever really scores 100.
虽然没人真的能得100分。
Oh, that's true. I took it myself for practice in nursing school. I got, like, an 80.
哦，那倒是。我在护理学校时为了练习自己也做过。我得了大概80分。
Yeah, for a perfect score, you'd have to be, like, Superman or something.
是啊，想要满分，你得是超人什么的。
No, no, no. You know who could get 100? What's that guy-- you know, that guy who can do anything including karate.
不，不，不。你知道谁能得100分吗？那个家伙——你知道，那个什么都能做，包括练空手道的家伙。
Leonardo da Vinci.
列奥纳多·达·芬奇。
No, no, no. He's dead. He would score poorly. [CHUCKLING] I was just--
不，不，不。他死了。他得分会很低。[轻笑] 我刚才只是——
No, the-- the speaker guy who can do anything! Jesus Christ, if I was him, I'd never forget anyone's name. Uh-- he helps you realize your full potential. He's six and a half feet tall. Come on, ladies. He's, uh--
不是，那个——那个什么都能做的励志大师！耶稣基督，如果我是他，我永远不会忘记任何人的名字。呃——他帮你实现全部潜能。他有六英尺半高。来吧，女士们。他，呃——
Tony Robbins?
托尼·罗宾斯？
Yes. Exactly. That guy. That guy, he could score 100.
是的。没错。那个家伙。那个家伙，他能得100分。
So as the medical professionals discussed how awakening the giant within can totally boost your neurological scores, one of the other nurses came and told me that earlier they had had to restrain my mom because even though she was unconscious, she'd somehow managed to get a hold of cigarettes. They caught her trying to light one in bed. We're not even sure where she got it, the nurse said.
所以当专业医疗人士讨论如何唤醒心中的巨人能如何提升神经系统评分时，另一位护士过来告诉我，说早些时候他们不得不限制我妈的行动，因为即使她在昏迷中，也设法搞到了香烟。他们抓到她在床上试图点烟。护士说，我们甚至不知道她从哪儿弄来的。
And that's when I knew my mother would be fine. Within days, she was sitting up, completely lucid, chatting up strangers-- everyone's favorite.
那一刻我知道我母亲会没事的。几天之内，她就坐了起来，完全清醒，和陌生人聊天——人人都爱她。
This time, things were bad enough that I called my brother Ethan. He can only come in a true emergency because he plays for the LA Philharmonic, and he has a couple kids, and his schedule's planned out months in advance. He took the red-eye straight from playing at Disney Hall.
这一次，情况糟糕到我不得不叫我弟弟伊森。他只能在真正的紧急情况下才能过来，因为他在洛杉矶爱乐乐团演奏，还有两个孩子，他的日程安排是几个月前就定好的。他刚在迪士尼音乐厅演出完就坐红眼航班赶来了。
Well, here we are again.
好吧，我们又到这儿了。
How you doing, man?
你怎么样，伙计？
I'm so glad you're here.
我真高兴你来了。
Thanks for coming.
谢谢你来。
Hey, buddy.
嘿，伙伴。
Good to see you.
见到你真好。
You holding up?
你还能坚持吗？
Yeah, I'm all right. Nice tux.
是的，我还行。漂亮的燕尾服。
Yeah. Thought my stage attire might help me look a little more official. She in there?
是的。我觉得我的舞台服装能让我看起来正式一点。她在里面吗？
Right now Ethan is working on a giant Mahler retrospective. They're going to play all nine symphonies. It's something that's never been done before.
伊森现在正在进行巨大的马勒回顾展。他们要演奏全部九部交响曲。这是前所未有的。
Oh, Ethan, this is Dr. Snyder.
哦，伊森，这是斯奈德医生。
Hi. It's nice to meet you. Your mother had a heart attack. She has severe respiratory distress, nearly septic infection. If we can get her  breathing on her own again, recovery is possible but would take a long time.
你好。很高兴认识你。你母亲心脏病发作了。她有严重的呼吸窘迫，近乎败血性感染。如果我们能让她再次自主呼吸，恢复是有可能的，但这需要很长时间。
And then what?
然后呢？
That's a good question.
那是个好问题。
No, that is a good question. If she needs in-home care, I don't think David could do it. They can't keep the cable on. And if she doesn't make it, what then?
不，那是个好问题。如果她需要居家护理，我不觉得大卫能应付。他们连网费都交不起。如果她挺不过去，那以后怎么办？
Where is he going to live?
他以后住哪儿？
Right? He can't stay at Century Village. I mean, it's a retirement community with a perimeter. It's like a geriatric army base. I don't know how he hasn't gotten kicked out already. They're definitely onto him. And if they realize mom isn't coming back--
对吧？他不能留在世纪村。我是说，那是个有围墙的退休社区。就像个老年军队基地。我不知道他到现在怎么没被赶出去。他们肯定盯上他了。如果他们意识到妈再也回不来了——
I'm sure we're going to get calls any day now.
我肯定我们迟早会接到电话。
Which one are you working on?
你在排练哪一部？
Oh. The 8th.
哦。第八部。
Oh, that's a big one, right?
哦，那是大部头，对吧？
Yeah, it's a big one. It has some really nice passages, though.
是的，大部头。不过有些段落真的很棒。
Mom, I know you can hear me. We love you, and we need you.
妈，我知道你能听到我。我们爱你，我们需要你。
What's it about?
那是讲什么的？
Eternal life.
永恒的生命。
[MUSIC - MAHLER'S  "SYMPHONY NUMBER 8"]
[音乐 - 马勒“第八交响曲”]
It's David who says that Mom would be happy that all three of her boys were together. And that's true. One of the few real senses of family I can recall was summers in the Midwest with her when we were all children years ago. And we made ice cream and caught fireflies and roller skated-- normal things like that. That's why David doesn't like being in the room much now, because he doesn't want to remember Mom like this, trapped in so many tubes. It's like some jacked-up Darth Vader shit, he says.
大卫说妈会很高兴看到她三个儿子聚在一起。那是真的。我能回想起来的极少数家庭真情实感的瞬间之一，就是我们小时候和她在中西部度过的夏天。我们做冰淇淋，捉萤火虫，溜旱冰——那些正常的事情。这就是大卫现在不太愿意待在房间里的原因，因为他不想看到妈变成这样，困在这么多管子里。他说，这就像某种糟糕的达斯·维达玩意儿。
And yet, he's the one who's been at her bedside the most. I can't bring myself to kiss her the way David does. I don't know why.
然而，他是待在床边最久的人。我没法像大卫那样吻她。我不知道为什么。
After Ethan goes back to California, I stay with David and Mom. Time is merciless in Florida and especially merciless in the ICU. Days turn into weeks, and every afternoon I pick up David, and we go to the hospital, talk to some doctors, wait, talk to some more doctors, and then maybe get dinner. Very little changes.
在伊森回加利福尼亚后，我和大卫陪着妈。在佛罗里达时间是无情的，在ICU里更是无情。日子变成周，每天下午我接大卫，我们去医院，和医生聊聊，等待，和更多医生聊聊，然后也许吃顿晚餐。几乎没什么改变。
Yo! Yo, I still want to show you that video I was telling you about.
哟！哟，我还是想给你看我跟你说的那段视频。
Oh. Yeah, right. OK.
哦。是啊，好吧。可以。
OK,  hold up. Hold up.
好吧，等一下。等一下。
In this very strange video, David's friend Sebastian, a completely grown man, is standing on some Florida crabgrass breakdancing robot-style. And the music is a tinny Casio-sounding version of "Fur Elise."
在这段非常奇怪的视频里，大卫的朋友塞巴斯蒂安，一个完全成年的人，正站在佛罗里达的螃蟹草地上跳机器人舞。背景音乐是卡西欧键盘那种单薄的声音演奏的《致爱丽丝》。
[MUSIC  - "FUR ELISE"]
[音乐 - “致爱丽丝”]
You know, he's pretty good.
你知道，他跳得真不错。
I know.
我知道。
But why is this happening?
但为什么会发生这种事？
I don't even really know. I mean, we were all just hanging out there in the driveway-- like, a bunch of us. Dude just starts doing the robot. He does that sometimes, right? And this one time, he was doing it in my face for a really long time-- for, like, a half hour. No, no-- I couldn't even believe it, man.
我甚至不知道。我是说，我们当时都在车道上待着——就是我们一群人。那家伙就开始跳机器人舞。他有时会这样，对吧？有一次，他在我面前跳了很长时间——有半小时那么久。不，不——我甚至都不敢相信，伙计。
That he could keep it up that long?
他能跳那么久？
No, more that I had to watch it for so long. Because I was, like, kinda trapped there, right? And at first, I was trying not to look. And then I couldn't look away.
不，更因为我不得不看了那么久。因为我当时，有点被困在那儿了，对吧？起初，我试图不看。然后我发现自己挪不开眼了。
Let me see that again.
再让我看一次。
OK, all right. Yeah, yeah.
好吧，好的。是啊，是啊。
[MUSIC - "FUR ELISE"]
[音乐 - “致爱丽丝”]
It was like I was in denial at first. And then I accepted it.
我起初像是在否认。然后我接受了它。
Like the stages of grief.
就像悲伤的阶段一样。
Exactly! Exactly. And then I reached some kind of state of bliss where it was so awesome that I was almost in tears.
正是！正是。然后我达到了一种极乐状态，这太棒了，以至于我都快掉眼泪了。
Yeah, I'm not sure that's exactly the Kubler-Ross model.
是啊，我不确定那是否准确对应库伯勒-罗斯模型。
Well, they should add that one-- the awesome state.
好吧，他们应该加上这一条——极乐状态。
It's nice spending time with David. But I'm also really worried about him. He's had a history with pills on and off over the years. And I suspect it's on again.
和大卫在一起时间过得很快。但我也真的很担心他。这些年来他断断续续地有药瘾史。我怀疑他又复发了。
One night while we're driving to dinner, David says, oh hey, Josh, can we stop over at the Victory? That's a gas station down on Okeechobee Boulevard. And Victory's a total misnomer for the kind of place where you pull in and just see a bunch of weird dudes crouching around the entrance, like it's a totally normal social spot.
一天晚上开车去吃晚餐时，大卫说，哦嘿，乔希，我们能在“胜利”站停一下吗？那是奥基乔比大道上的一个加油站。胜利是个完全名不符实的名称，那种地方你开进去只能看到一群奇怪的家伙蹲在入口附近，就像那完全是个正常的社交场所。
And David knows everyone here, which is weird. And I'm pretty sure something illicit is happening but I don't want to ask, because I don't want to be The Man with David. And he probably wouldn't tell me anyhow. Ah, it's nothing, David says. Sure, just your regular nighttime rendezvous in the parking lot of an off-brand gas station.
大卫认识这里所有人，这很怪。我敢肯定这里在进行某种非法勾当，但我不想问，因为我不想在大卫面前当“大人物”。而且他反正也不会告诉我。大卫说，啊，没啥。当然，就在品牌加油站的停车场里来一场常规的夜间约会。
David gets back in the car, and he says, all right, I'm good. But I'm not so sure. It's weird, but Mom and David are a team-- like a fucked-up crazy team for a long time, but a team nonetheless. And they've taken care of each other. And the question on my mind is if Mom doesn't make it whether David will.
大卫回到车里，说，好了，我搞定了。但我不太确定。真怪，但妈和大卫是一个团队——长期以来那种糟糕的疯狂团队，但不管怎样是团队。他们一直照顾彼此。我脑子里的问题是，如果妈挺不过去，大卫是否能挺过去。
All right, guys. She might destabilize immediately, but if she makes it, we'll load her up and get her over to the hospice facility right away.
好了，伙计们。她可能会立刻恶化，但如果她撑住了，我们会把她装上车立刻送往临终关怀中心。
Yeah, I'm just-- I'm a little concerned that she understands you. I mean, I think that she can hear you.
是的，我只是——我有点担心她能不能理解你。我是说，我觉得她能听到你说话。
Oh, I know this can be hard for you, an adjustment to end-of-life care is always--
哦，我知道这事儿对你们很难，调整到临终关怀总是——
I mean, she's right there.
我是说，她就在那儿。
Right. Do you have any other questions?
好的。还有别的问题吗？
Well, I was wondering--
嗯，我在想——
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I was wondering about Xanax.
是的。是的，是的。是的。我在想赞安诺。
Uh, she's already getting Ativan, which is also for anxiety. It's part of the hospice program. So she--
呃，她已经在服用阿提万了，那也是抗焦虑的。那是临终关怀项目的一部分。所以她——
No, I meant for me. Look, I'm not talking, like, a whole prescription or anything. I'm just asking if you could hook me up with, like, a couple, you know, for right now.
不，我是指给我的。听着，我不是说要整张处方什么的。我只是问你能不能给我弄几片，你知道，为了现在。
I'm sorry. I can't accommodate that request.
抱歉。我没法满足那个请求。
I'm gonna go outside and smoke. This shit is getting a little too real for me right now.
我要出去抽根烟。这事儿对我来说现在有点太真实了。
The hospice is nice-- institutional, but warm. Like, people are allowed to bring pets and stuff. One lady even brought her horse, the intake guy was very excited to tell us.
临终关怀中心不错——制度化但温暖。比如，人们可以带宠物之类的。 intake的人很兴奋地告诉我们，甚至有位女士带了她的马。
I spent some time going through Mom's things. I find her address book, which is a mess, stuffed with Post-Its and scraps, bearing faded numbers in Mom's perfect cursive.
我花时间翻了翻妈的东西。我找到了她的地址簿，乱七八糟的，塞满了便利贴和纸条，上面用妈那种完美的草书写着褪色的号码。
How can we call her friends? I don't know who's who. I mean, no one visited her in the hospital.
我们怎么联系她的朋友？我不知道谁是谁。我是说，医院里没人看望她。
[PHONE VIBRATING]
[电话震动]
We should have called people sooner.
我们早该打电话给别人的。
She doesn't really have that many friends around anymore. And I'm telling you, she didn't want visitors at the hospital.
她周围真的没几个朋友了。我告诉过你，她不想让别人去医院看她。
Yes, but they might want to see her.
是的，但他们可能想见她。
Well, I don't have her friends' numbers.
好吧，我没有她朋友的电话。
David, I need you to help me figure this out.
大卫，我需要你帮我弄清楚这件事。
[PHONE VIBRATING]
[电话震动]
I gotta take care of some shit right now.
我得去处理点事情。
Where are you going? Dude, you've been wandering in and out of here for weeks. Is it pills or what?
你去哪儿？伙计，你这几个礼拜在这一进一出好几回了。是因为药还是什么？
Nah. Nah, it's Sebastian, right? He's got this other friend who called him, and--
不。不，是塞巴斯蒂安，对吧？他有个别的朋友给他打电话，然后——
So? That can wait. What is with all the weird petty dramas? Half the time you're pacing around on your phone dealing with some crisis, like Jimmy Carter at Camp David.
所以呢？那事儿能等。那些奇怪的小打小闹算什么？你有一半时间都在在那儿踱步打电话，处理某种危机，就像戴维·坎普时期的吉米·卡特一样。
Well, I got Peggy's number.
好吧，我有佩吉的电话了。
Well, why didn't you tell me that before?
那为什么你不早告诉我？
You didn't ask?
你没问啊？
Dude! This is when you call people. When your mother is dying, you call her fucking friends.
伙计！这时候就该打给别人。当你母亲快去世时，你要打给她的朋友。
Yo, she can hear you. And I know that you want to be all mad at me right now because you're mad at yourself or something, but this whole situation is fucked up. I accepted it a long time ago.
哟，她能听到你说话。我知道你现在想冲我发火，因为你对自己发火或者什么，但这整件事都搞砸了。我很久以前就接受了。
I accept that it's fucked up. I've been here for six weeks.
我接受了它搞砸了。我在这待了六个礼拜了。
And I appreciate everything that you have done. But I've been here the whole time-- when Mom fell and knocked herself out or when I found her in the backyard or when I took her to get the last of her teeth removed. I wish it was different, but it is what it is. Mom is my best friend.
我也很感激你所做的一切。但我一直都在这儿——妈摔倒撞晕的时候，我发现她在后院的时候，或者我带她去拔掉最后几颗牙的时候。我希望情况能不同，但现实就是这样。妈是我最好的朋友。
And you, you're gonna get to go home. And I'm going to be the one who's stranded here. Now, I have to go. Sebastian locked himself in his garage somehow. And you should call Peggy, but do that shit outside.
至于你，你待会儿就能回家了。而我将是被困在这里的那个人。现在，我得走了。塞巴斯蒂安不知怎么把自己锁在车库里了。你应该给佩吉打电话，但去外面打。
I finally bring myself to start holding Mom's hands, and she rubs my palm. I think David's right. She knows.
我终于让自己开始握住妈的手，她揉了揉我的掌心。我想大卫是对的。她知道。
Each time, her grip gets a little stronger. I look in her terrified eyes and see my own. One night, just before I leave for the day, she takes my hand with both of hers. It's the biggest show of purpose in weeks. And for a second, I don't see the tubes, the room, the cracked lips, or her papery fingers. No one else is here. It's just us.
每一次，她的抓力都强一点。我看着她恐惧的眼睛，看到了我自己的眼神。一天晚上，就在我离开前，她用双手握住我的手。这是几周以来最大的用意表现。在那一瞬间，我没看到管子、房间、裂开的嘴唇或她像纸一样的手指。这里没有其他人。只有我们。
The next morning, there was a message on my phone from the hospice before I got up. I know-- they always say it was peaceful. And they made arrangements with the King David Cemetery for the next day.
第二天早上，我在起床前收到了来自临终关怀中心的一条留言。我知道——他们总是说走得很平静。他们第二天在大卫王公墓做了安排。
Damn, my stomach hurts. I can't tell if it's this funeral stuff or from that bacon, egg, and cheese biscuit I ate this morning.
该死，我胃疼。我分不清是因为这葬礼的事还是因为我今天早上吃的那块培根鸡蛋奶酪饼。
Hm. I mean, I'm going to guess it's the former.
嗯。我是说，我猜是前者。
I don't know. That shit was pretty gross. You want to hear something funny? So, I was at home earlier today, right, watching TV, just trying to take my mind off of things, you know?
我不知道。那玩意儿真够恶心的。你想听点有趣的吗？所以，我今天早些时候在家，正在看电视，只是试着把心思从这些事情上挪开，你懂吗？
And then all of a sudden, the TV goes black. And I'm like, oh, shit. This is all I need right now. So I find this cable bill from before Mom went into the hospital. It was, like, $15, but she forgot to pay it, as usual.
然后突然间，电视黑了。我心想，哦，该死。这正是我现在需要的。于是我找到了妈住进医院前的一张电费账单。那大概15美元，但她一如既往忘了交。
And the whole thing was, like, such a Mom-type scenario, you know? I mean, it's just exactly the type of thing that she would have done. So when the TV went black, I-- I kinda thought it was like Mom saying a little hello. I'll be OK.
整件事，真是个太像妈会干的事的剧本了，你懂吗？我也就是说，这正是她会干出来的那种事。所以当电视黑掉时，我——我觉得那就像妈在打个小招呼。我会没事的。
I hope so.
希望如此。
All right. Let's get rolling.
好了。我们出发吧。
[RABBI CONDUCTING THE SERVICE IN THE BACKGROUND]
[背景里拉比主持仪式]
The sun is low on the horizon beneath the clouds, bringing up steam from the grass. If you include the funeral director and the two Haitian dudes lounging on tombstones waiting to fill in the grave, there are only nine people listening.
太阳在云层下低垂在地平线上，从草地上蒸发出水汽。如果算上殡仪馆馆长和两个懒散地靠在墓碑上等着填土的海地兄弟，总共只有九个人在听。
The scene feels like a frontier funeral, a clutch of poor souls standing around a pine box, like we should leave here in a covered wagon and keep heading west and just be glad the devil's drink didn't bury us, too.
这场景感觉像边疆葬礼，一群穷苦灵魂站在松木棺材周围，就像我们该乘着敞篷马车离开这里，继续西行，只庆幸魔鬼的饮料没把我们也埋了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Joshuah Bearman. In the scenes, Josh Hamilton played him. James Ransone played his brother David. Matt Marks was Ethan and played the French horn. Our doctors were Bhavesh Patel and Seth Barrish, who also played the rabbi. Nurses were Carolyn Baeumler and Zakiya Young. Terry Kinney directed the story on the stage.
乔希·贝尔曼。在场景中，乔希·汉密尔顿扮演他。詹姆斯·兰索恩扮演他弟弟大卫。马特·马克斯扮演伊森并演奏法国号。我们的医生是巴韦什·帕特尔和赛斯·巴里什，他还扮演了拉比。护士由卡罗琳·巴姆勒和扎基亚·杨扮演。特里·金尼在舞台上指导了这个故事。
So we've been planning for months that Stephin Merritt was going to sing a song at this point in the show. And we told Josh Bearman a couple weeks ago. And he was like, oh my god, that's crazy. My mom-- his mom in the story-- used to babysit for Stephin Merritt. It's true-- when Stephin was a kid growing up outside Boston, Josh Bearman's mom Susan babysat for him. So please welcome, Stephin Merritt.
我们几个月前就计划好了，斯蒂芬·梅里特要在这时候唱首歌。我们几周前告诉了乔希·贝尔曼。他当时说，哦天哪，这太疯狂了。我妈——故事里的那个妈——以前给斯蒂芬·梅里特当过保姆。这是真的——当斯蒂芬在波士顿郊外长大时，乔希·贝尔曼的母亲苏珊当过他的保姆。所以请欢迎，斯蒂芬·梅里特。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[MUSIC - "HOW DO YOU SLOW THIS THING DOWN?" BY STEPHIN MERRITT]
[音乐 - 斯蒂芬·梅里特演唱“怎么减慢这东西的速度？”]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Stephin Merritt, with Pinky Weitzman on violin and Sam Davol on cello. Stephin Merritt plays in a number of bands. His latest album is from The Magnetic Fields. It's called Love at the Bottom of the Sea .
斯蒂芬·梅里特，与小提琴手平基·怀兹曼和大提琴手萨姆·达沃尔。斯蒂芬·梅里特在多个乐队演出。他最新的专辑来自磁场乐队。叫《深海里的爱》。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Act Four, "Bus, Stop!" This next story is something that comedian Sasheer Zamata has been telling onstage in her stand-up act. And we asked her to adapt it into a full-on radio drama with actors and a sound man, like a classic radio drama. In fact, we have two sound men doing sound effects with a table full of props. Please welcome Sasheer Zamata.
第四幕，“巴士，停！”下一个故事是喜剧演员萨希尔·扎马塔在她的脱口秀里讲的。我们邀请她把它改编成一个有演员和音效师的完整广播剧，就像经典的广播剧一样。事实上，我们有两个音效师，桌上摆满了道具。请欢迎萨希尔·扎马塔。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
A few years ago, I got into an accident on a shuttle bus. My friend Nicole and I rented a car, and we were dropping it off at LaGuardia airport. We got onto the rental car company's shuttle bus to get taken to the cab stand to get a cab to go home. And we were the only two passengers on the bus.
几年前，我在一辆摆渡车上出了车祸。我和朋友妮可租了一辆车，我们正把它送到拉瓜迪亚机场。我们上了租车公司的摆渡车，打算去出租车等候区叫辆车回家。我们是车上仅有的两名乘客。
Hey, you two sure you want to sit back there? Because, ha-ha, I drive pretty crazy.
嘿，你们两个确定要坐那儿吗？因为，哈哈，我开车挺疯狂的。
[NERVOUS CHUCKLING]
[紧张的轻笑]
OK!
好的！
OK.
好的。
We heard him say this, but we didn't believe him. We should have believed him. Because that's exactly what he did.
我们听到了他这么说，但没当真。我们该当真的。因为他确实就是那么做的。
[BRAKES RELEASING]
[刹车释放声]
He sped out of the parking lot and towards the airport. And Nicole and I were in the back, humoring him and playing up the wild ride.
他飞速开出停车场，朝机场驶去。我和妮可在后排，顺着他的玩笑话，配合着这趟狂野之旅。
Woo! This is crazy!
哇！这太疯狂了！
And then he hits the brakes really hard.
然后他猛地踩下刹车。
[BRAKES  SQUEALING]
[刹车尖叫声]
Whoa! Too crazy!
哇！太疯狂了！
And then we hit another car in the intersection.
然后我们在十字路口撞上了另一辆车。
[RUMBLING]
[轰鸣声]
Way too crazy!
太疯狂了！
There's no seat belts on the bus, and Nicole goes falling into the luggage carry in front of her. I go flying into the air and headed towards the driver's seat.
车上没有安全带，妮可摔进了她前面的行李架里。我飞向空中，正对着驾驶座。
Now, if I was walking this distance, it would probably take me, like, 10 seconds. But because I'm flying through the air, it takes me, like, two. And I think now I understand why flying is the fastest way to travel.
现在，如果我是走这段距离，大概需要10秒。但因为我正飞在空中，只用了2秒。我觉得现在我明白为什么坐飞机是旅行最快的方式了。
[CLUNK]
[哐当]
Ow!
噢！
I'm lying on the floor, and my head is pounding. And I just think, wow, that was the most realistic example of foreshadowing I've ever seen. Two seconds ago, this guy says, I drive crazy. And then he did. And then we got into an accident. I don't know why I thought anything different would happen.
我躺在地板上，头痛欲裂。我心想，哇，这是我见过最现实的伏笔示例了。两秒前，这家伙说，我开车疯狂——然后他就开车疯狂了。然后我们出了车祸。我不知道为什么我刚才会以为会有什么不同的结果。
Hey, you OK?
嘿，你还好吗？
No. Everything sucks. I want to go home.
不好。一切糟透了。我想回家。
No, you can't go home. You hit your head.
不，你不能回家。你撞到头了。
Yeah, I know. But it's fine.
是的，我知道。但没事。
No, it's not fine. We have to go to the hospital. Your face is, like, twice the size it should be.
不，没没事。我们得去医院。你的脸肿得比正常大了一倍。
We get off the bus, and the cops are already there. I see the car that we hit, and it's a tiny red car. And we T-boned it. Except the T is very disproportionate, where the top part of it's very tiny and the bottom part's a huge bus.
我们下了车，警察已经在那里了。我看到了我们撞到的那辆车，那是一辆小红车。而且我们从侧面撞了它。除了那个T字形很不匀称，上半部分很小，下半部分是一辆大巴士。
Did you ladies see what happened?
女士们看到发生了什么了吗？
No, we were sitting at the back of the bus, and we couldn't actually see the traffic.
没有，我们坐在巴士后面，实际上看不到路况。
OK.
好的。
But the bus driver did it.
但巴士司机干的。
But you just said you didn't see anything.
但你刚才说你什么都没看见。
Yeah, but he said, (IMITATING) I drive crazy-- before the accident, and then he did drive crazy.
是的，但他刚才说了，（模仿）我开车疯狂——在事故之前，然后他就开得疯狂了。
A concept that was still blowing our minds.
这个概念当时还冲击着我们的脑子。
But you didn't see the accident?
但你没看到事故？
No, we didn't. But how could  it have been the other guy's fault? We were on the bus that hit him. Also, can someone take my friend to the hospital? She hit her head real hard.
没有，我们没看到。但怎么可能是对方的错？是我们坐的这辆巴士撞了他。还有，谁能带我朋友去医院？她头撞得很厉害。
Nicole was amazing in high-stress situations-- like the time when I told her I was pregnant.
妮可在高压环境下很棒——就像我告诉她我怀孕时那样。
Um, yeah, so, we didn't use a condom. And I haven't had my period in a while.
嗯，是的，所以，我们没用避孕套。而且我已经很久没来例假了。
It's OK. This is fine. OK, I support whatever you want.
没事。这很好。好的。我支持你想做的任何决定。
I don't know what I'm supposed to tell my family.
我不知道我该怎么告诉家人。
Oh, listen. I will go with you to the clinic, or if you don't want me to, whatever you want.
哦，听着。我会陪你去诊所，或者如果你不想让我去，你想怎么样都行。
I just-- I can't have a kid right now.
我只是——我这会儿没法要孩子。
No, no, no. I know. Come here. It's going to be OK. I love you, OK?
不，不，不。我知道。过来。会没事的。我爱你，好吗？
OK.
好的。
I love you.
我爱你。
All right.
好吧。
OK?
好吗？
OK. Um, I really appreciate this. And-- April Fools!
好的。嗯，我真的很感激。而且——愚人节快乐！
What the fuck?
他妈的怎么回事？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
What the fuck is wrong with you?
你这人他妈的怎么了？
See? She's a great friend. And the perfect person to have for this stupid bus accident. We get onto an ambulance and head towards the hospital. And the driver of the other car is already there. And he's much chattier than most would be after getting into a serious accident like this.
看吧？她是个好朋友。也是经历这次愚蠢的巴士车祸的最佳人选。我们上了救护车朝医院开去。另一辆车的司机已经在那里了。他比大多数出严重车祸的人健谈得多。
So you guys were on that bus?
所以你们坐的是那辆巴士？
Oh. Uh, yes. We were.
哦。呃，是的。我们坐的。
It was a rental company bus. Did you rent a car?
那是一家租赁公司的车。你们租车了吗？
Uh, yeah. We rented a car to go to Boston.
呃，是的。我们租了辆车去波士顿。
Oh, cool. What was going on in Boston?
哦，酷。波士顿有什么好玩的？
Um, we were there for a festival.
嗯，我们要去参加一个节日。
What kind of festival?
什么节日？
A comedy festival.
喜剧节。
Wow! So you're a comedian?
哇！那你也是喜剧演员？
Yes.
是的。
Does that mean you're a comedian, too?
那意味着你也是喜剧演员了？
Don't talk to me!
别跟我说话！
I don't know why I just didn't do that! Telling a person who's not a comedian that you're a comedian is never good because the conversation that follows is always terrible.
我不知道为什么我刚才没直接那么做！告诉一个非喜剧演员你是喜剧演员永远不是好事，因为随后的谈话总是很糟糕。
So you were up in Boston. Did you make any jokes about baked beans? They love those up there.
所以你们在波士顿。你们有讲过关于烤豆的笑话吗？他们在那儿特别喜欢那个。
No, I didn't make any jokes about baked beans.
不，我没讲过关于烤豆的笑话。
Listen, next time you're in Boston, you say, (KENNEDYESQUE ACCENT) pahk the cah. It'll kill. It will kill. You can have that one. That one's yours. You can have that for free.
听着，下次去波士顿，你就说，（模仿肯尼迪口音）停车。这会笑死人的。这会很火。那个笑话送给你。那个是你的。免费送给你。
OK, thank you. Thank you so much. I'm gonna stop talking now because my head really hurts.
好的，谢谢。非常感谢。我现在要闭嘴了，因为我头真的很痛。
(SNORTING) I get it.
（发出嗤笑声）我懂。
It's not a joke.
这不是笑话。
I get it.
我懂。
I don't want to say the name of the hospital that we went to because someone here in the audience may actually work there. But we went to Elmhurst Hospital. And it was the dirtiest hospital I've ever been to in my life. There were Toblerone wrappers on stretcher beds and loose muffins on the floor-- just, like, unwrapped, unexplained, whole muffins.
我不想说我们去的医院的名字，因为在座的观众可能有人就在那儿工作。但我们去了埃尔姆赫斯特医院。那是我这辈子去过最脏的医院。担架床上有瑞士三角巧克力包装纸，地板上有散落的松饼——就是那种没包装、无法解释、一整块的松饼。
I'm left with Nicole in the waiting room. And we're waiting and waiting. Nicole's actually really scared of what would happen to me if I fell asleep. So she makes it her job to make sure I stay awake.
我被留在那和妮可在候诊室。我们一直在等。妮可实际上很担心如果我睡着了会发生什么。所以她把确保我保持清醒当成了自己的任务。
Hm?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yeah?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Mm-hmm?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yeah?
嗯？
You see that doctor over there?
你看到那个医生了吗？
Uh-huh.
呃哼。
Would you fuck him?
你会跟他上床吗？
You said he's a doctor, right?
你说他是医生，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
So probably, yeah.
那很可能，是的。
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yeah?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Mm-hmm?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yeah?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yes?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yes?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Hm?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yes?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yes?
嗯？
Sasheer?
萨希尔？
Yes?
嗯？
Are you hungry?
你饿吗？
Always.
一直都很饿。
You want a muffin?
你想吃个松饼吗？
Always.
一直都想。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Go get that muffin.
去拿那个松饼吧。
I'll get that muffin.
我去拿那个松饼。
Get that muffin.
去拿那个松饼。
I'm gonna get that muffin.
我去拿那个松饼。
Go get that muffin.
去拿那个松饼。
I'm gonna get--
我要去拿——
Go get that muffin.
去拿那个松饼。
I'm gonna get it.
我去拿它。
Go get that muffin! Go get that muffin!
去拿那个松饼！去拿那个松饼！
I got it.
我拿到了。
You got that muffin!
你拿到了那个松饼！
I got it!
我拿到了！
Oh, no! No, no, no, no. That's a dirty muffin. Put that muffin down.
哦，不！不，不，不，不。那是脏的松饼。把那松饼放下。
[MUMBLING].
[嘟囔]。
Oh, no. Maybe eat that candy off the chair.
哦，不。也许吃那椅子上的糖果。
OK. There's nothing in here.
好的。这儿什么都没有。
Oh, no! The hot doctor must have eaten it all! He loves chocolate.
哦，不！那帅医生肯定全吃光了！他最爱巧克力。
Ah. Does that mean he'll love me?
啊。那意味着他会爱我吗？
You're a big old chocolate woman, so yes! But you gotta stay awake. Doctors hate sleepy bitches.
你是位巧克力美人，所以是的！但你得保持清醒。医生讨厌睡着的婊子。
Yeah.
好的。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I don't want to be a sleepy bitch.
我不想当个睡着的婊子。
Mm-mm. Because you know what they say about sleepy bitches.
嗯嗯。因为你知道他们怎么评价睡着的婊子的。
What?
什么？
They too tired!
她们太累了！
Five hours pass, and I still haven't gotten seen.
五个小时过去了，我还没被看到。
Excuse me, do you know how much longer before I get seen?
打扰一下，你知道我还要等多久才能被诊治吗？
What you need to be seen for?
你需要诊治什么？
I was just in a car accident. I need someone to check my head.
我刚出了车祸。我需要有人检查我的头。
Oh! I didn't know you were in a car accident. We thought you were waiting on somebody. You look fine.
哦！我不知道你出了车祸。我们以为你在等人。你看起来没事。
But I hurt!
但我很痛！
Eventually I get moved to the CAT scan area, and the guy running the scan looks like he's 12 years old, and he's, like, not putting me at ease.
最后我被转移到了CT扫描区，负责扫描的那个家伙看起来才12岁，而且他一点也没让我感到轻松。
OK. So what happened to you?
好的。那么你发生什么事了？
I was just in a car accident.
我刚出了车祸。
Oh. I couldn't tell. You look fine.
哦。我看出来。你看起来很好。
That's what I hear.
大家都这么说。
Whoa! Cool gold shoes! Did you spray-paint those yourself?
哇！酷毙了的金色鞋子！你自己喷漆喷的吗？
I did!
是的！
That's so cool! I want to get this one pair of sneakers with this design that has--
太酷了！我想买那种设计是——
OK, can you just scan me, please?
好的，能请你快点扫描我吗？
[MACHINE WHIRRING]
[机器嗡嗡声]
He finally scans me. And then I wait awhile for the results.
他终于扫描了我。然后我等了一会儿结果。
You're fine.
你没事。
Every person involved with this accident was awful. Except for Nicole. She was the best part of this whole thing. So ladies and gentlemen, I'd like to present to you the last best person in New York State, Nicole Byer!
这起事故涉及的每个人都很糟糕。除了妮可。她是整件事中最棒的部分。所以女士们先生们，我想向大家介绍纽约州最后一位好人，妮可·拜尔！
[FANFARE]
[号角声]
When God comes back and says if there's one just person, one righteous person, I will not destroy the world-- oh, um, OK. OK, so I will just not--
当上帝回来并说如果有一个正义的人，一个义人，我就不会毁灭世界——哦，嗯，好吧。好吧，那我只是不会——
It's Ira. Uh, radio listeners, internet listeners, what's happening now onstage is that people are running on giving Nicole flowers and cheering her.
我是艾拉。呃，广播听众们，互联网听众们，现在舞台上发生的事是人们跑上台给妮可送花并为她欢呼。
OK. That's-- that's enough. All right, I still-- I hit my head really hard in the accident.
好的。那——那够了。好吧，我还是——我事故中头撞得很厉害。
OK. Well, thanks a lot for listening to my--
好的。嗯，非常感谢大家听我的——
[LIGHTS   TURNING OFF]
[灯光熄灭]
--story.
——故事。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
There was some artistic license taken with actual dialogue. The dialogue in that story at the hospital was not reported verbatim. We contacted Elmhurst Hospital about the conditions Sasheer saw, asked for a comment. The spokesperson said she'd get back to us this Wednesday. Didn't get around to it. We reached out a few more times, and we never heard back.
对实际对话采用了一点艺术加工。医院里那个故事的对话并非逐字报道。我们联系了埃尔姆赫斯特医院关于萨希尔看到的条件，请他们置评。发言人说她会在周三回复我们。结果没能回复。我们又联络了几次，始终没收到回音。
Sasheer Zamata with Nicole Byer, Chris Gethard, Frank Garcia Hejl, Tony Ward, Zakiya Young, Seth Barrish, and 12-year-old Matthew Mindler as the CAT scan guy.
萨希尔·扎马塔，与妮可·拜尔、克里斯·格哈德、弗兰克·加西亚·海尔、托尼·沃德、扎基亚·杨、赛斯·巴里什，以及12岁的马修·明德勒饰演CT扫描男。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Well, our program was produced today by myself with Robyn Semien and Robert Saenz de Viteri, with our senior producer, Julie Snyder, Alison Davis, and Elise Bergerson, as well as Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由我自己制作，罗宾·塞米恩和罗伯特·萨恩斯·德·维特里协助，我们的资深制片人朱莉·斯奈德、艾莉森·戴维斯和伊莉斯·伯格森，以及亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·凯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦、布莱恩·里德、艾丽莎·希普、南希·厄普代克。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Some music in today's show by Roger Neill. Thanks to Laura Coburn. Thanks to all the theater professionals who took their time out from their day jobs to be here with us for a week and to be here today-- singers, actors, dancers, writers, composers, directors, and some actual famous people.
赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制片经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维兹管理我们的网站。研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔。今天的节目中有罗杰·尼尔的配乐。感谢劳拉·科本。感谢所有从日常工作中抽出时间陪伴我们一周，并在今天到场的剧院专业人士——歌手、演员、舞者、编剧、作曲家、导演和一些真正的名人。
And especially thanks to the core production team led by Robert Saenz de Viteri, Christine Jones set designer, Andrea Lauer costume design, Mark Bartun lighting design, Nevin Steinberg sound design, Ann McPherson stage manager, the BAM crew, they all had to use incredible I have to say cunning and craft to get a show this complicated into a theater and tech it in in one day. We got here this morning.
特别感谢由罗伯特·萨恩斯·德·维特里领导的核心制作团队，舞美设计师克里斯汀·琼斯，服装设计安德里亚·劳尔，灯光设计马克·巴顿，音响设计内文·斯坦伯格，舞台经理安·麦克弗森，BAM的工作人员，不得不说他们运用了令人难以置信的聪明才智和技艺，把这么复杂的节目在一天内装进剧院并排演完毕。我们今天早上才到。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can see everything that was on today's show, the sets, the costumes, the dancing, and, like, seriously half an hour of incredible material that was simply too long to include on the radio, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以看到今天节目里的一切，布景、服装、舞蹈，还有，真的很认真地讲，半小时令人难以置信的内容因为太长而没法放进广播里，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder, Torey Malatia. I will never forget the crazy birthday party where he ate slice after slice of German chocolate cake. And we kept telling him, Torey, stop with the German chocolate cake. Stop it. You're going to make yourself sick. And we were right. He made himself sick. He was green and sick and then couldn't stop saying--
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。我永远忘不了那个疯狂的生日派对，他一片接一片地吃德国巧克力蛋糕。我们一直告诉他，托里，别吃了。停下。你会把自己吃病的。我们是对的。他确实把自己吃病了。他脸色发绿，难受极了，然后不停地说——
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
[德语]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。